I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Angela! Hey! We are so excited today, you guys. We're going to the beach today. We're going to play some beach games. Yes! Season 3, episode 22, written by Jen Solata and Greg Daniels, directed by Harold Ramis. It's beach games. We have so much to talk about. I kind of feel like we just got to, we just got to get to it. We should dive in because I took very diligent
我是珍娜·菲舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室娇娃。安吉拉！嘿！大家，我们今天太兴奋了。我们今天要去的沙滩。我们要去玩一些海滩游戏。耶！第三季，第22集，由詹·索拉塔和格雷格·丹尼尔斯编剧，哈罗德·雷米斯导演。这是海滩游戏。我们有太多要聊的了。我感觉我们得直接进入正题了。我们应该深入探讨，因为我做了非常认真的
notes. And I think you did in real life. We'll get to that. Alright, here's a summary. Michael is invited to interview for a job opening at corporate. Certain that he's a lock for the job, he takes his employees to the beach at Lake Scranton and holds a series of challenges to determine his successor. At the end of the day, Michael sets up a coal walk as a final challenge. Pam does the coal walk and summons up the courage to tell Jim and the whole office her real feelings. Oh, man. That was, that was so tough to watch. It was beautiful, Jenna. Pam broke my heart in this episode. Yeah, I had not seen this episode since it aired. And I, it shocked me. And I did it. And I was still shocked. Is that funny? Like
笔记。我想你在现实生活中也是。我们等会儿会说到这个。好吧，这里是个总结。迈克尔被邀请去总公司参加一个工作空缺的面试。他确信自己稳操胜券，于是带着员工前往斯克兰顿湖的海滩，并举行了一系列挑战来决定他的继承人。在一天结束时，迈克尔安排了一场走炭火作为最终挑战。帕姆走了炭火，鼓起勇气向吉姆和整个办公室表达了她的真实感受。哦，天哪。那真是，太难看了。很美，珍娜。在这集里，帕姆心碎了。是的，自从这集播出以来我就没看过。而且我，这让我很震惊。而我做了。我还是感到震惊。是不是很搞笑？就像
the way the brain works where you're like, wait, I did all that. That's crazy. That's kind of cool. Yeah. Yeah. So fast fact number one, Angela, our beach games is set on Lake Scranton. Yes. Obviously, we didn't go to the real Lake Scranton, but I did want to just talk a little bit about it. Oh, let's hear it. Well, Lake Scranton is actually a reservoir and it was built with a dam in the early 1900s. The dam was built by William Walker Scranton and the body of water it created was originally called the Burnt Bridge Reservoir, although the public calls it Lake Scranton. Well, Jenna, you and I have both been to Scranton and one of the times that I went, they drove me around Lake Scranton and it is so pretty. So pretty.
大脑运作的方式，你会想，等等，这一切都是我做的。这太疯狂了。这有点酷。是啊。是啊。所以快讯一号，安吉拉，我们的海滩游戏设定在斯克兰顿湖。是的。显然，我们没有去真正的斯克兰顿湖，但我确实想简单聊聊它。哦，说来听听。嗯，斯克兰顿湖实际上是一个水库，它是在20世纪初通过修建大坝建造的。这座大坝由威廉·沃克·斯克兰顿修建，它所形成的水体最初被称为“烧毁桥水库”，尽管公众称之为斯克兰顿湖。嗯，珍娜，你我都去过斯克兰顿，我去的其中一次，他们带我参观了斯克兰顿湖，它真的太漂亮了。太漂亮了。
There is a running track around the real Lake Scranton. And it's absolutely gorgeous. But I did look up a few facts about it, Ange. Yeah. Swimming is not permitted. Boating is not permitted, but canoeing and kayaking is allowed. I wonder why you can't swim in it. Like I get the no motor, right? That's like right. Like, I think that's sort of really cool. But I wonder why the no swimming. I don't know. Hmm. I'm not sure. We're intrigued. Scranton ride us. Tell us why you can't swim in your lake. Well, this leads me to fast fact number two. I brought up all these facts about Lake Scranton because we had a fan question from Sophia B, Aaron W, Dana D, Marin B and Fabie. Where was the beach that you filmed this episode?
真正的斯克兰顿湖周围有一条跑步跑道。而且绝对美极了。但我确实查了一些关于它的资料，昂热。是的。不允许游泳。不允许划船，但允许划独木舟和皮划艇。我不知道为什么不能在里面游泳。就像我理解的不能用发动机对吧？那就像是对的。就像，我觉得那真的很酷。但我想知道为什么不能游泳。我不知道。嗯。我不确定。我们很好奇。斯克兰顿，快联系我们。告诉我们为什么你们的湖里不能游泳。嗯，这就引出了快讯二号。我提出了所有这些关于斯克兰顿湖的事实，因为我们收到了来自索菲亚·B、亚伦·W、达娜·D、马琳·B和法比的粉丝提问。你们是在哪个海滩拍摄这一集的？
Was it a long commute and how many days did you film at that location? Well, I will tell you. Tell us. I know I remember one or two things, but I bet you got all the details. Let's hear it. Well, I reached out to Kentopedia and here's what he told me. We filmed at the beach at the Hanson Dam Recreation Center in Silmar. We shot there for four days and nights. Will you mention that you've been to the real Lake Scranton? I've been to this real Hanson Dam Recreation Center outside of us filming. You have? Yes, because there is this museum, this children's museum called the Discovery Cube that's right nearby. When you go through this area, there's also an equestrian center, there's an aquatic center, there's a playground
通勤时间很长吗，你们在这个外景地拍摄了几天？好吧，我来告诉你。快告诉我们。我知道我记得一两件事，但我敢说你掌握了所有细节。说来听听。嗯，我联系了肯托百科，以下是他告诉我的。我们在锡尔马的汉森大坝娱乐中心的沙滩上拍摄的。我们在那里拍摄了四天四夜。你会提到你去过真正的斯克兰顿湖吗？除了拍摄之外，我还去过这个真正的汉森大坝娱乐中心。去过？是的，因为那里有一个博物馆，一个叫发现魔方的儿童博物馆就在附近。当你穿过这个区域时，还有一个马术中心，一个水上中心，一个游乐场
because lady, the place that they put us to film this episode was like, I had no idea all this stuff was there. My memory of where we filmed was it was like a chemical pond runoff from a dam where I was like, are we breathing in fumes? It was really gross. Maybe the only place they let you film is in this weird janky corner of this area. Where the runoff water goes. Yeah, because this recreation center is actually really nice. Here's something I found out too. The lake where we filmed is filled with circulated drinking water. What? Yeah, circulated drinking water and it offers fishing and public boating. Oh my gosh. So when Ed is out there floating in the water, he was in some recycled drinking water. Oh,
因为姑娘，他们安排我们拍摄这一集的地方，我简直不知道所有这些东西都在那里。我对我们拍摄地点的记忆就像是一个大坝排出的化学池污水，当时我在想，我们是在吸入毒气吗？真的很恶心。也许他们唯一允许你拍摄的地方就是这个地区的这个奇怪的破旧角落。污水流过的地方。嗯，因为这个娱乐中心其实非常棒。这也是我发现的一件事。我们拍摄的湖里装满了循环饮用水。什么？是的，循环饮用水，它提供钓鱼和公共划 boating。哦天哪。所以当埃德漂浮在水里时，他其实是在一些回收饮用水里。哦，
well, that's good to know. All these years I worried for him that he was going to get like some kind of weird rash. All right, well, let's move on to fastback number three. So like we said earlier, this was written by both Greg Daniels and Jen Salada and we reached out to Jen Salada and she sent us audio clips. She sent us so many. She's so gracious. We're going to sprinkle them throughout, but here she has one for us right now. Yes, she is going to tell us a little bit about the inspiration for this episode and what it was like to write a script with Greg. I think the inspiration for this episode was just survivor. I think it was Greg's idea. And I remember all of us talking about survivor being a perfect
好吧，这倒是个好消息。这些年来我一直担心他会感染某种奇怪的皮疹。好了，我们继续快讯三号。就像我们之前说的，这集是由格雷格·丹尼尔斯和詹·萨拉塔共同编剧的，我们联系了詹·萨拉塔，她给我们发了音频片段。她发了好多。她太客气了。我们会在节目中穿插播放，不过她现在这里正好有一个片段。是的，她要给我们讲讲这一集的灵感来源，以及和格雷格一起写剧本是什么感觉。我想这集的灵感来源就是《幸存者》。我想这绝对是格雷格的想法。我记得我们所有人都讨论过《幸存者》是一个完美
way for Michael Scott to pick his successor. I mean, what other way would this man use to try to pick somebody who could run a branch? It just seemed like a no brainer for Michael Scott to do it this way. And then we tried to sit down and write the whole thing together and we were like, this isn't going to work. So we divided it up. We can't remember exactly how we did it. I think sometimes with Paul, when I write a script with Paul, I do the first half, he'd do the second or vice versa. And with Greg, I think we didn't do cleanly divided up that way. I think just he did some of the scenes. I did others. And I do remember that the Pam speech was mostly Greg. And I think that is such a beautiful part of the
让迈克尔·斯科特挑选继承人的方式。我的意思是，这个男人还会用什么其他方式来试图挑选一个能够管理分公司的人呢？让迈克尔·斯科特用这种方式来做简直是再合适不过了。然后我们试图坐下来一起写完整的内容，我们当时觉得，这行不通。所以我们把它分开了。我们记不清具体是怎么做的了。我想有时候和保罗一起，我和保罗写剧本时，我写前半部分，他写后半部分，反之亦然。至于格雷格，我觉得我们没有那么明确地分开。我觉得只是他写了一些场景。我写了其他的。而且我确实记得帕姆的演讲主要是格雷格写的。而且我认为那是这一集中非常美妙的一部分。
episode. And the Pam arc pre existed the idea of the beach games episode. So I think some of the ideas from that speech were in his notes. But I love that part. It is one of my favorite parts, not my favorite part of the episode. So credit to Greg for that part for sure. But we both wrote a bunch of it. I just don't think we clearly divided it up. Well, and I remember Greg talking to me about this Pam arc of her finding her voice. Yeah. And he planted this idea a few episodes ago, and we sprinkled it in. And so I just love this idea that he'd been maybe writing down little notes about what Pam will finally say when she says something. And I remember getting the script for this episode. And just being
而且帕姆的成长线在海滩游戏这一集之前就已经存在了。所以我认为演讲中的一些想法已经在他的笔记里了。但我很喜欢那部分。这是我最喜欢的部门之一，不，是我这一集中最喜欢的部门。所以这部分绝对要归功于格雷格。不过我们俩都写了很多。我只是觉得我们没有明确分工。嗯，我记得格雷格跟我谈过帕姆找到自我声音这条成长线。是的。他在几集前就埋下了这个伏笔，我们把它融入了进去。所以我非常喜欢这个想法，关于他可能一直在写一些小纸条，记下帕姆最终说出那番话时会说些什么。我记得拿到这集剧本的时候。并且作为
so excited as an actor, there was just so much to chew on. I mean, I thought that it was just beautifully done. Really, just Pam's whole journey this season about even her sending the wrong beer back, you know what I mean? And yeah, and just having these moments where she stood up for herself and spoke her truth. And it all builds to this one moment. And it's just so well done. When I was rewatching this, I was marveling at what a well written episode this was. Yes. Well, maybe we should take a quick break and then come back and break down this episode. I can't wait, Jenna, we have so much to talk about. I know, we've been trading a lot of texts about this one.
一个演员感到非常兴奋，有太多东西可以细细琢磨了。我的意思是，我认为这真的做得太棒了。真的，仅仅是帕姆这一整季的旅程，甚至包括她把错误的啤酒退回去，你知道我的意思吗？还有，是的，只要有这些她为自己挺身说出真相的时刻。这一切都在这一刻爆发了。而且做得太棒了。当我重温这一集时，我惊叹于这是一集多么优秀的剧本。是的。好吧，也许我们应该快速休息一下，然后回来剖析这一集。我等不及了，珍娜，我们有太多要聊的了。我知道，我们为这一集发了很多短信。
All right. So this episode starts with this very funny cold open. It is Dwight and Michael. They're in Michael's office. And Michael's convinced that he's sick, you guys. He's convinced they're scrolling through a website. It's like WebMD or something trying to figure out what he is sick from. Dwight's very concerned. Yes. Pam has a talking head where she explains that this happens about 40 times a year. Michael, it's sick but has no symptoms. Yes. Well, Jen left us a really great audio clip about this, about the inspiration for this cold open. Sam, can you play that? Greg and I wrote the episode together and it was really fun. I remember being really curious.
好了。所以这集开始于这个非常搞笑的冷开场。是德怀特和迈克尔。他们在迈克尔的办公室里。迈克尔确信自己生病了，伙计们。他确信他们在浏览一个网站。就像WebMD之类的，试图找出自己得了什么病。德怀特非常担心。是的。帕姆有一个直面镜头的独白，她解释说这种情况一年大约发生40次。迈克尔，他生病了但没有任何症状。是的。詹给我们留了一个非常棒的关于这个冷开场灵感的音频片段。萨姆，你能播放一下吗？我和格雷格一起写了这一集，真的很有趣。我记得我真的很好奇。
What is Greg's process going to be like? Because writing scripts, it was such a solitary part of what we did. And so I was always wondering, like, what are other writers like when they go off to write a script? It became quickly obvious that his process at the beginning was like mine, which is like every other writer I've ever met, which is there's a fair amount of procrastinating right away before you have to get into the hard work. It's figuring out what you want to eat. It's sharpening your pencils. It's figuring out the temperature of the room. And for both of us, we started focusing on ailments, like what was wrong, how we weren't feeling well, like my ear was bothering him and he wasn't feeling super
格雷格的创作过程会是什么样？因为写剧本，这是我们所做的事情中非常孤独的一部分。所以我总是想知道，其他编剧去写剧本时是什么样子的？很快就很明显，他刚开始时的过程和我一样，就像我见过的所有其他编剧一样，那就是在必须开始艰苦的工作之前，一开始会有相当多的拖延。那就是弄清楚你想吃什么。那是削铅笔。那是弄清楚房间的温度。对我们俩来说，我们开始关注各种病症，比如出了什么问题，我们感觉哪里不舒服，比如我的耳朵一直在烦扰他，而他当时
well at the time. And so we went on WebMD and we tried to diagnose ourselves and each other. And they used to have a little body where you could like point to the part of the body that hurt and that was bothering you. And so he diagnosed me with an ear infection or at least inner ear congestion. And he ended up putting some oil from the kitchen that we found in my ear. It turns out you can do this. It is, it is a home remedy. And it helped. It helped my ear. And I think we diagnosed him with walking pneumonia. So we did this right when we were sent off to write the Beach Games episode. And it ended up becoming our cold open, because we were probably looking for a cold open and we're like, what about
感觉其实不是很好。所以我们上了WebMD，试图诊断我们自己和彼此。他们过去有一个小人体模型，你可以指着身体疼痛和困扰你的部位。所以他诊断我得了耳部感染，或者至少是内耳充血。他最后把我从厨房找到的一些油滴进我耳朵里。事实证明你可以这么做。这确实是一个偏方。而且它起作用了。它对我的耳朵有帮助。我想我们诊断他得了散发性肺炎。所以就在我们被派去写《海滩游戏》这一集时，我们做了这些。它最终成为了我们的冷开场，因为我们可能在找一个冷开场，然后我们想，不如就用
what we're doing right now? There is so much about that audio clip that I love. It's so relatable. It's like whenever you sit down to do something that doesn't matter what it is. I mean, there's was this writing assignment, but all the different ways you procrastinate before you get to that thing. Yes. Well, Angela, you and I are working on a project that we can't say exactly what it is, but it involves quite a bit of writing. And I, every time I sit down to write, I will write one sentence and then I will get up and get a snack. And then I'll come back and
我们正在做的事情？那个音频片段里有太多我喜欢的内容了。太有共鸣了。就像每当你坐下来要做某事时，不管那是什么。我的意思是，这是一个写作任务，但你在做那件事之前会用各种不同的方式来拖延。是的，安吉拉，你和我在做一个项目，我们不能确切地说它是什么，但它涉及到相当多的写作。而我，每次我坐下来写作，我都会写一个句子，然后我会起来吃点零食。然后我会回来
write a sentence and then I'll be like, I need more coffee. Yeah, it's like the procrastination. I loved that she shared that because I think my perception is always that creativity comes easy to people who are successful. I always think like it must pour out of them. And it is such a slog. So I loved hearing that. But then the other thing I loved was that their procrastination, it got turned into a story idea. Like it's worth it. Like all of that nonsense, it produced something. Right. Well, I had a writing professor in college that used to always say, write what you know, write what you know, and it will be honest.
写一个句子，然后我会想，我需要更多的咖啡。是的，就像是拖延症。我很高兴她分享了这一点，因为我一直以来的印象是，对于成功的人来说，创意来得很轻松。我总是认为灵感一定是从他们身上倾泻而出的。而这其实是一场苦战。所以我很高兴听到这个。但另一件我喜欢的事是，他们的拖延症竟然变成了一个故事创意。这很值得。就像所有那些胡思乱想，它产出了某些东西。对。好吧，我在大学里有一位写作教授，他总是说，写你所知，写你所知，这就会很真诚。
Oh, well, I just loved this, this opening. And, you know, before they can really diagnose Michael, Pam walks in the office and says, David Wallace is on the phone. Yeah. It's very clear that David Wallace does not call very often. No, it's a big deal. Well, Michael gets on the phone with him. Oh my goodness. Michael, what are you doing? Well, the way Michael talks to his bosses are even when he goes to New York to corporate, there is such a casualness to how he relates to them that is so not work appropriate. It's so true. Well, we find out the reason that David Wallace is calling is because there is a job opening at corporate and he would like Michael to apply. I can't believe he still
哦，好吧，我真的很喜欢这个开场。而且，你知道的，在他们真正能诊断出迈克尔之前，帕姆走办公室说，大卫·华莱士在打电话。是的。很明显，大卫·华莱士不经常打电话。不，这是个大事件。好吧，迈克尔接了他的电话。哦，天哪。迈克尔，你在干什么？嗯，迈克尔和他的老板们说话的方式，甚至当他去纽约总公司时，他对他们的态度有一种随性，太不符合工作规范了。太真实了。好吧，我们发现大卫·华莱士打电话的原因是因为总公司有一个职位空缺，他希望迈克尔申请。我不敢相信他仍然
wants Michael to apply after this phone call, but I think Michael has a very, very good sales record and a good record of connecting with people out in the sales world. Yeah, he's a really good salesman. Here's a little interesting tidbit, Jenna. There was a scene that was deleted right after this phone call of David Wallace and Michael. David Wallace calls Jim and tells Jim the same thing. I saw that in the script and they chose not to use it. They chose to reveal it later that it's Jim calling. It's Jim being more proactive in his life, but there was a version where David calls Jim. Yeah, I noticed that in the script because that scene on the beach with Jim and Karen
想让迈克尔在打了这通电话后申请，但我认为迈克尔有着非常非常好的销售记录，并且在销售界有着与人沟通的良好记录。是的，他是个非常好的销售员。这里有个有趣的小花絮，珍娜。在大卫·华莱士和迈克尔这通电话之后，有一个被删掉的场景。大卫·华莱士打电话给吉姆，告诉吉姆同样的事情。我在剧本里看到了，但他们选择不使用它。他们选择稍后才揭晓是吉姆打来的电话。这是吉姆在生活中变得更加积极主动，但曾有一个版本是大卫打电话给吉姆。是的，我在剧本里注意到了，因为吉姆和凯伦在海滩上
calling David and asking if they could go for the job as well, that was not in the original script. That must have been something that they added later. Well, I remember when we were at the beach, there were a few scenes that sort of happened on the fly. They were like kind of pitched in the moment and that was one of them. So now it is beach day and at two minutes, 28 seconds, you get a fantastic look at Michael's outfit. He clearly bought everything he could at Sandals in the gift shop. He's got a t-shirt, he's got a hat, he has a necklace that he probably bought there, a little pucachel necklace. He's really ready and he tells everyone they better go potty before they leave. I'm just
打电话给大卫并询问他们是否也可以去争取这个职位的场景，并不在原剧本中。那一定是什么他们后来添加的东西。嗯，我记得我们在海滩上时，有一些场景可以说是即兴发挥的。它们就像是在那一刻随兴想出来的，而那就是其中之一。现在是海滩日，在2分28秒时，你可以很好地欣赏一下迈克尔的行头。他显然把桑德尔斯度假村礼品店里所有能买的东西都买下了。他穿着一件T恤，戴着一顶帽子，戴着一条他可能在那儿买的项链，一条小贝壳项链。他真的准备好了，他告诉大家在离开前最好去上个厕所。我只是
like, Michael's so ready to be a dad. You know, he just is, bless his heart. And you get to see everybody in casual attire and I just loved it. Well, I noticed something about our wardrobe. What's that? Do you see how many layers we all have on? Oh, well, that was for a reason. Yep. It was because we shot this episode in March and we knew that that location was going to be perfectly warm and lovely during the day. It turned out to be hot as F. There was a heat wave. There was this crazy freak March heat wave. It was 98 degrees.
觉得，迈克尔太渴望当爸爸了。你知道，他就是那样，真拿他没办法。你能看到每个人都穿着休闲服，我太喜欢了。嗯，我注意到我们的服装有个细节。什么细节？你看到我们身上穿了多少层衣服吗？哦，那是有原因的。是的。那是因为我们在三月份拍摄这一集，我们知道那个外景地在白天会非常温暖宜人。结果热得要命。当时有热浪。有一股疯狂的罕见的三月份热浪。气温达到了98华氏度。
I wrote in my journal that it was 98 degrees our first day. Yeah. But then when the sun went down, it was freezing cold. Yeah. We're in this valley. So it was like these really huge swings of temperature. Yeah. So wardrobe tried to give us layers to help take us between these two extreme temperatures and I noticed when I was looking at everyone's beach attire. They're layers. Well, you know what? I noticed this is really, really fun to me. Toby and Angela almost have on the same outfit. What? I did not notice that.
我在日记里写到我们第一天有98华氏度。是的。但当太阳下山时，冷得要命。是的。我们在这样一个山谷里。所以温差非常巨大。是的。所以服装部门试图给我们穿多层衣服来帮助我们在两个极端温度之间过渡，当我看着大家的沙滩装时，我注意到了。它们都是叠穿的。好吧，你知道吗？我注意到这个，我觉得真的真的很有趣。托比和安吉拉穿的几乎是一模一样的衣服。什么？我没有注意到。
They're both wearing these beige tops. They have huge beige floppy hats and like sort of like just like pants on. But like, and they're also both obsessed with sunscreen. Both of them. Well, I noticed that both Andy and Stanley are wearing a red polo shirt. Oh, yeah. I did not catch that. But guess what? I did catch. And I know it's your favorite moment of the day. Is it a new plant at reception? Because we need a sting for this new plant alert. Three minutes, 32 seconds. It is a red flowering plant. There are big red flowers on this plant.
他们都穿着米色上衣。他们戴着巨大的米色宽边帽，还穿着那种差不多的裤子。而且，他们两个都对防晒霜着迷。两个人都是。嗯，我注意到安迪和斯坦利都穿着红色Polo衫。哦，是的。我没注意到这个。但你猜怎么着？我确实注意到了。我知道这是你一天中最喜欢的时刻。是前台的新植物吗？因为我们需要为这个新植物警报配个音效。3分32秒。这是一株开红花的植物。这植物上有大红花。
Okay. I'm sorry. I see that as a metaphor because Pam is going to bloom in this episode. That is so good. Pam's going to flower. She's going to bloom. But we forgot to talk about how Michael has told Toby he can't come on the beach day. Oh, that was so good. Toby's disappointment. He doesn't get to see you in a two piece. Jenna, I wrote, how did you get through that scene without laughing? I did. How did you do it? Because when you were like, oh, thanks, I'm going to wear my two piece. His face is so good.
好吧。对不起。我觉得这是一个隐喻，因为帕姆在这集里要绽放了。太棒了。帕姆要开花了。她要绽放了。但我们忘了谈论迈克尔如何告诉托比他不能去海滩日。哦，那太棒了。托比太失望了。他看不到你穿比基尼了。珍娜，我写道，你是怎么忍住不笑拍完那场戏的？我是说，你是怎么做到的？因为当你说，哦，谢谢，我要穿我的比基尼时。他的表情太棒了。
It's so funny. We also didn't mention, and I'm tracking this, the Meredith flash count. This is flash number two. Yes. Meredith has that great talking head where she explains that she wore her bathing suit to work. Yeah. And she lifts her shirt to show you and she's like, oh shoot, it's in my purse. Michael has a special assignment for Pam on beach day.
太搞笑了。我们还漏掉了一点，我一直在留意这个，梅雷迪思的闪光次数。这是第2次闪光。是的。梅雷迪思有一个精彩的直面镜头独白，她解释说她穿着泳衣上班。是的。她掀起衬衫给你看，然后她说，哦糟了，它在我的钱包里。迈克尔给帕姆在海滩日安排了一个特殊任务。
Of course, because she needs an assignment. Yeah. Michael tells her that she has to take notes all day on people's character, humor, charisma, and the indefinable qualities that they possess, but not their hotness per se. I loved that line. Yeah. Per se. She could add that if she wanted, but it's not 100% necessary, I guess. But he also doesn't tell her why she has to do this. No. He just needs to find out which of his employees has the skills to be a chicken
当然，因为她需要一个任务。是的。迈克尔告诉她，她必须整天做笔记，记录人们的性格、幽默感、个人魅力以及他们拥有的不可言喻的特质，但不是他们的性感本身。我太喜欢这句台词了。是的。本身。如果她想的话她可以加上，但这并不是100%必要的，我猜。但他也没告诉她为什么要这么做。不。他只是需要找出他哪个员工具备成为一个头脑简单的
with a head. That's right. That makes sense. What? Well, let's see. Now the gang is all going to board the bus. Michael's got a big party bus to take everyone to the beach. Yeah. Crete's got a boogie board. He's ready to go. Yeah. Kevin says he just wants to lay on the beach and eat hot dogs. It's literally
傻瓜的能力。没错。这说得通。什么？好吧，我们来看看。现在大家都要上大巴了。迈克尔弄了一辆豪华派对大巴带大家去海滩。是的。克里德拿了个滑板。他准备好出发了。是的。凯文说他只想躺在海滩上吃热狗。简直是
all he's ever wanted. Now this bus that we're all riding in, we really rode in that. That's how we got to the beach. It was the first day, but then the days after that, we drove ourselves. Yes. That first day, though, they shuttled us from the stages, and the plan was that we would use the time to shoot the scene with Michael. But then we had extra time. Yeah. So we all started singing.
他一直以来梦寐以求的。现在这辆我们都在坐的大巴，我们确实坐了。我们就是这样去海滩的。那是第一天，但之后的几天，我们都是自己开车。是的。不过第一天，他们用班车把我们从舞台接送过来，原计划是利用这段时间拍迈克尔的那场戏。但后来我们有富余时间。是的。所以我们都开始唱歌了。
Well, listen, I watched the DVD commentary for this, and I thought it was so sweet because Harold Ramis is on the DVD commentary. And Jen Salada was on it as well. And Jen was like, you know, Harold said, I'd never been on a bus where we didn't sing. Yeah. He was like, everybody, when you get on a bus with people, you sing, right? That was Harold Ramis being genius. And I do know two other songs we sang, Jenna. Do you remember? Yeah.
好吧，听着，我看了这个片段的DVD评论音轨，我觉得太温馨了，因为哈罗德·雷米斯也在DVD评论音轨里。珍·萨拉达也在里面。珍就说，你知道的，哈罗德说，我从没坐过一辆大家不唱歌的大巴。是的。他就像是，每个人，当你和大家一起坐大巴时，你们都会唱歌，对吧？那是哈罗德·雷米斯天才的一面。而且我知道我们唱另外两首歌，珍娜。你还记得吗？是的。
What? We sang Tiny Dancer. Oh, yes. And then we also sang Friends, and we did the hand claps. I remember that. Yeah. I didn't know all the words to that, so I just clapped. Well, Angela, I have to say, I remember that vibe of us just singing our way to the beach that very first day. And then, frankly, as we walked off the bus and got hit in the face
什么？我们唱了《Tiny Dancer》。噢，是的。然后我们还唱了《Friends》，我们还拍了手。我记得那个。是的。我不会这首歌的所有歌词，所以我只是拍手。嗯，安吉拉，我得说，我记得那天我们一路唱歌去海滩的那种氛围。然后，坦白说，当我们走下大巴，迎面扑来
with that 98 degree weather, I feel like you see that play out on our faces. I felt the same thing in rewatching this. That shot when we're walking across the beach, we're all carrying our stuff. Meredith is dragging a cooler. Do you know the shot I'm talking about? I took a photo of it because I think it's so amazing. I took a screen grab. That is all real. That struggle to drag that stuff across the beach, and it was hot. You guys have all been there. You've been to that beach where you had to park super far away and lug your stuff in the heat, and all your enthusiasm of getting there is so quickly like, oh, God,
那98度（华氏）的天气，我觉得你能在我们的脸上看到那种反应。我在重温这一段时也有同感。当我们走过海滩时的那个镜头，我们都拿着自己的东西。梅雷迪思拖着一个冷藏箱。你知道我在说哪个镜头吗？我拍了张照片，因为我觉得太棒了。我截了屏。那全都是真的。拖着那些东西穿过海滩的那种挣扎，而且天气很热。你们大家都有过这种经历。你去过那个海滩，不得不把车停在超级远的地方，然后在炎热中艰难地搬运行李，你到达那里的所有热情很快就会变成，哦，天哪，
here we go. Well, Angela, you mentioned a little bit about the challenges of this location, and Jen talked about that as well. So, Sam, will you play that audio clip number eight? It was a super fun episode, but it was really challenging. I remember even the bathrooms weren't close to the location. So, and there was close as they could be, but we needed a golf cart. And so anytime anybody had to go to the bathroom, there was a golf cart taking people up a hill. And I remember it was super hot and super cold all within the course of one day. There were heat lamps and hand warmers, and then it was really, really
我们开始吧。嗯，安吉拉，你稍微提到了这个外景地的挑战，珍也谈到了这一点。所以，萨姆，你能播放一下第八段音频剪辑吗？这是一个超级有趣的剧集，但确实很有挑战性。我记得甚至洗手间离拍摄地点都不近。所以，虽然它们已经尽可能近了，但我们需要一辆高尔夫球车。因此，每当有人要去洗手间时，就会有一辆高尔夫球车把人带上山。我记得在一天之内，天气一会儿超级热，一会儿超级冷。有加热灯和暖手宝，然后在下午
hot in the middle of the afternoon. So everything about this episode was a challenge, and I feel like we just, in order to get everything great, it just took a long time. Oh, yeah. It was Slim Pickens out there on the beach. I mean, we had just enough room to shoot. There was, I mean, I remember us just being huddled under like a little pop-up tent or something. Yeah. I mean, when I was looking at the photos that I have, there's nothing out there. Once we were on the beach, we're sort of on our own because things couldn't be in the shot. They did get us like some lawn chairs. I have this great photo, Jenna, of Steve and I sitting next to each other, clearly between a scene. And we're just like
正午又非常非常热。所以这集的一切都是个挑战，我觉得为了拍出完美的镜头，我们真的花了很多时间。哦，是的。海滩上真是资源匮乏啊。我的意思是，我们只有刚刚够用的拍摄空间。那儿，我的意思是，我记得我们只是挤在一个小快开帐篷或者类似的东西下面。是的。我的意思是，当我看着我拍的照片时，外面什么都没有。一旦我们在海滩上，我们就只能靠自己了，因为东西不能入镜。他们确实给我们弄了一些草坪椅。珍娜，我有一张很棒的照片，我和史蒂夫并排坐着，显然是在两场戏之间。我们就像
in lawn chairs, like just hanging out and talking. I just love it. And also this week, Jenna, I brought my football. Okay. In real life, I had it in my car. And when they would have some setups to do, in particular, like when they were setting up the hot dogs and all that, I have these photos of us throwing the football on the beach. We were having our own beach day. So yes, it was sort of like there weren't bathrooms nearby and it was hot, but we were also just making our own fun. And we always did that. I felt like as a group, Jenna, we were really just kind of roll with it and make the best of it. And I always loved that about our show.
坐在草坪椅上，只是闲逛聊天。我真的很喜欢。而且这周，珍娜，我带了我的橄榄球。好吧。在现实生活中，它就在我的车里。当他们有一些布景工作要做时，特别是他们在摆放热狗之类的时候，我有这些我们在海滩上扔橄榄球的照片。我们在过我们自己的海滩日。所以是的，虽然附近没有洗手间而且天气很热，但我们也在自己找乐子。我们总是这样。我觉得作为一个群体，珍娜，我们真的就是那种顺其自然并尽量做到最好的人。我一直很喜欢我们节目的这一点。
All right. Well, let's see. Where are we? We've arrived. We're ganking our stuff down the beach. And Michael tells us it's time to start the funtivities. Such a great word. I want to use it. It's like nifty gifties, funtivities. Can you imagine if I did that like at a family reunion? All right, everybody, it's time for funtivities. I love it. I know. Personally. I would both be excited. We'd want to be on the funtivities, like organizing group. The funtivities committee.
好吧。嗯，让我想想。我们到哪儿了？我们到了。我们把东西拖下海滩。迈克尔告诉我们，是时候开始“趣味活动（funtivities）”了。一个多么棒的词。我想用它。就像精美礼品（nifty gifties）、趣味活动（funtivities）。你能想象如果我在家庭聚会上这么做吗？好了，各位，是时候进行趣味活动了。我喜欢。我懂。就我个人而言。我们俩都会很兴奋。我们会想加入趣味活动，就像组织小组一样。趣味活动委员会。
The funtivities committee. Or the committee to plan funtivities. Or what was wrong with my brain? The funtivities organizing group. What? Mama needs another cup of tea. Well, Michael tells everyone that they have to divide into teams. He picks the team leaders quote unquote randomly. They are Jim Dwight, Andy, and Stanley. These guys are clearly his top contenders for the job. And he makes them choose their tribes. Yes.
趣味活动委员会。或者计划趣味活动的委员会。或者我的脑子怎么了？趣味活动组织小组。什么？妈妈需要再来一杯茶。好吧，迈克尔告诉大家他们必须分成小组。他“随兴”挑选了队长。他们是吉姆、德怀特、安迪和斯坦利。这些人显然是他心中的这份工作头号竞争者。他让他们选择各自的部落。是的。
But not Pam. And they cannot be included. Pam can't be included in. And also, these are the team names. Ready? Yes. We have Gryffindor, Voldemort, Blue, and USA. It's incredible. Yes. Well, I loved all of these Harry Potter references. You know, my son is right in that age range where we've got Harry Potter over here. And we reached out to Jen about this.
但没有帕姆。他们不能被包括在内。帕姆不能被包括在内。而且，这些是队伍名称。准备好了吗？有的。我们有葛莱芬多、佛地魔、蓝色队和美国队。太不可思议了。是的。嗯，我喜欢所有这些《哈利·波特》的梗。你知道，我儿子正处于那个年龄段，我们这边也看《哈利·波特》。我们为此联系了珍。
Yeah. What was up with the Harry Potter thing? Yeah, I was so curious. I was like, was this like an inside joke in the writer's room? And this is what Jen had to say. We had a bunch of Harry Potter fans in the writer's room. It even evolved to a situation where we had chopsticks hanging around the room from takeout. You know, we ate a lot of our meals in the writer's room. And so one afternoon we decorated our chopsticks while we were probably pitching stories and jokes. We each decorated chopsticks and then we had,
是的。《哈利·波特》是怎么回事？是的，我太好奇了。我想，这是编剧室里的内部笑话吗？珍是这么说的。我们在编剧室里有一群《哈利·波特》迷。它甚至发展到这样一种情况：我们房间里到处挂着外卖用剩的筷子。你知道的，我们的很多饭都在编剧室里吃。所以一天下午，我们在构思故事和笑话的同时，把我们的筷子装饰了一番。我们每个人都装饰了筷子，然后我们有，
we were pretending that they were Harry Potter wands and we would do spells on each other. Probably just comedy spells. But we even had wand stands near the writer's room door that were just little thumbtacks, you know, spread apart so that we would rest our wands on them. So everybody had their Harry Potter chopstick wands and our wand stands. And that sounds super dorky. And I believe it is. It was really fun. Just again, what the writers were doing to procrastinate made it into a script. Yeah, I feel like there's probably more of that than we will ever know. Yes, exactly.
我们假装它们是《哈利·波特》的魔杖，我们会互相施咒。大概只是喜剧魔咒吧。但我们甚至在编剧室门附近有魔杖架，那只是几个图钉，你知道的，隔开一段距离，这样我们就可以把魔杖搁在上面。所以每个人都有他们的《哈利·波特》筷子魔杖和魔杖架。这听起来超级书呆子气。而且我相信确实如此。真的很有趣。同样，编剧们用来拖延时间的把戏竟然写进了剧本里。是的，我觉得这样的事情可能比我们想象的还要多。是的，完全如此。
All right. So at seven minutes, six seconds, Michael has his big survivor speech. Now, you guys, we've shared this before, but our camera operators, Randall and Matt, both worked on Survivor. So this had been a little bit of an interesting callback for them, right, Jenna? Yes. And how prepared were they to lug cameras on their shoulders on a beach? I mean, these guys, they were like, oh, I've come full circle. Yeah, bring it. So Michael says this, a group of Americans will undergo the ultimate challenge. One day, 14 strangers who worked together, but only one survivor. And they're all like,
好吧。所以在7分6秒时，迈克尔发表了他的《幸存者》长篇大论。现在，伙计们，我们以前分享过这个，但我们的摄像师兰德尔和马特都曾在《幸存者》工作过。所以这对他们来说是一个有点有趣的温故知新，对吧，珍娜？是的。他们扛着摄像机在海滩上拍摄的准备工作做得怎么样？我的意思是，这些家伙，他们就像是，哦，我兜了个圈子又回来了。来吧，尽管放马过来。所以迈克尔说，一群美国人将经历终极挑战。一天，14个曾一起工作的陌生人，但只有一个幸存者。他们都觉得，
what? What's about to happen here? Well, what's about to happen is a spoon and egg race, Angela. Oh yeah. Except the person with the egg will be blindfolded. Also, Jenna, I don't know if you remember this, but poor Brian, they had him in the background. He's just eating his egg. He's eat and it didn't make it on camera. And I remember feeling so bad that Brian in the course of this time in the heat had to eat hard boiled eggs and hot dogs. I was like, this poor guy. And also, I think it's very funny that Michael hard boiled the eggs.
什么？这里要发生什么？好吧，接下来要发生的是勺子运蛋比赛，安吉拉。哦，是的。只不过拿蛋的人会被蒙上双眼。还有，珍娜，我不知道你是否还记得这个，但可怜的布赖恩，他们把他安排在背景里。他一直在吃他的鸡蛋。他在吃，而且这没有被拍进镜头里。我记得感到非常难过，布赖恩在这个闷热的时刻不得不吃水煮蛋和热狗。我想，这个可怜的家伙。而且，我觉得迈克尔把鸡蛋煮熟了这一事实非常搞笑。
Yes. Because then if they fall off the spoon, it doesn't matter. There's no point. There's no point. Now I am wondering, and I don't know the answer, I'm speculating, but I wonder if we had to hard boil the eggs because we couldn't risk having eggs break on the beach. Oh. We were kind of leaving behind that kind of debris because when we left there, we had to make it seem like we'd never been there at all.
是的。因为如果它们从勺子上掉下来，也没关系。毫无意义。毫无意义。现在我在想，我不知道答案，我只是在猜测，但我想知道我们是否必须把鸡蛋煮熟，因为我们冒不起鸡蛋在海滩上打破的风险。哦。我们有点在留下那种残渣，因为当我们离开那里时，我们必须让它看起来好像我们从未去过那里一样。
Not only that, but there's no way we could be dealing with wardrobe issues with egg yolk. Yes, exactly. But I like to think that it was just Michael's strange choice, but it was probably a very, very practical one. Oh, I'm sure it was very thought out. I wrote, what the heck? Who was setting up these teak heat torches? Where did the blindfolds come in? Who carried the eggs? Who had the spoons? What is happening? Oh, Angela, I don't know if it's in the deleted scenes, but in the script, there was an extra scene where Dwight discovers these boxes of supplies that Michael has packed in the back
不仅如此，我们根本无法应对蛋黄带来的服装问题。是的，完全如此。但我愿意认为这只是迈克尔奇怪的选择，但它可能是一个非常非常实用的选择。哦，我确信这是经过深思熟虑的。我写下，搞什么鬼？是谁在搭建这些柚木加热灯？眼罩是从哪里来的？谁搬的鸡蛋？谁拿的勺子？这到底是怎么回事？哦，安吉拉，我不知道这是否在被删减的片段中，但剧本里有一个额外的场景，德怀特发现在大巴后面迈克尔打包的这些物资箱子
of the bus. And he's trying to get Michael to tell him what they are. What are the torches for? What is this for, Michael? And Michael's like, stop badgering me. That is in the deleted scenes, but it's just a bag where he's trying to zip up and Dwight's like, is that a sumo suit? Are we going to do Japanese business exercises? But none of the other supplies are seen. And I guess my whole point is fine. Fine, Jenna. He had the supplies on the back of the bus. Who's setting them up? Where's my B-roll footage of Dwight having to run around and stab teak heat torches in the ground?
他正试图让迈克尔告诉他这些是什么。这些火炬是用来做什么的？迈克尔，这个是用来做什么的？迈克尔却说，别烦我。那是在被删减的片段中，但那只是一个包，他正试图拉上拉链，而德怀特却说，那是相扑服吗？我们要进行日本商业锻炼吗？但没有看到其他物资。我想我的全部重点是，好吧。好吧，珍娜。他把物资放在了大巴后面。是谁在搭建它们？我关于德怀特不得不四处奔跑并将柚木加热火炬插进地里的B面花絮镜头在哪里？
Well, I know I'm jumping ahead, but later we're going to see two guys setting a giant fire pit thing. With a red pickup truck. Who are these dudes? I guess I don't know. Michael had some assistance. Okay, we just have to suspend belief a little bit, guys. I guess so. Well, during this egg race, at nine minutes, 54 seconds, you can fully see Mindy starting to laugh.
嗯，我知道我扯远了，但后来我们会看到两个人正在搭建一个巨大的火坑似的东西。开着一辆红色的皮卡车。这些家伙是谁？我想我不知道。迈克尔有一些助手。好吧，伙计们，我们只需要稍微暂停一下现实感。我想是的。嗯，在这场运蛋比赛中，在9分54秒时，你可以清楚地看到曼迪开始笑了。
Oh, yeah. When Ed is yelling at her, when she's afraid she's going to run into the big rock, yes, she starts laughing. Yes. And I personally love how Ryan says to Dwight, if you keep shouting at me, I'm going to stop. I'm going to stop this race. And he doesn't stop shouting. So he just takes off his blindfold and throws his spoon on the ground. Now, Jenna, I think there's a portion of that scene that was on the fly kind of scene and that was improvised dialogue between BJ and Rain. That's what they talked about in the DVD commentary.
哦，是的。当埃德对她大喊大叫时，当她害怕自己会撞到大石头上时，是的，她开始笑了。是的。我个人很喜欢瑞安对德怀特说的话，如果你继续对我吼，我就不干了。我要终止这场比赛。但他并没有停止大吼。所以他只是摘下眼罩，把勺子扔在地上。现在，珍娜，我认为那个场景的一部分是即兴发挥的那种场景，那是BJ和雷恩之间即兴发挥的对话。这就是他们在DVD评论音轨中谈到的内容。
Yes. Do you remember that? Yes. Yes. That's right. Well, now Pam has her talking head where we see that she's taking her diligent notes. And we had some fan questions from Lily S, Ashley Hildreth and Madison Barton. Jenna, did you really write the notes? And if so, what did you write? I'm with you. I want to know too. I'm like, I know my BFF and I'm guessing you actually were writing things down. What were you doing? I was taking diligent notes. I knew it. I knew it.
是的。你还记得吗？是的。是的。没错。好吧，现在帕姆有了她的访谈镜头，我们看到她在认真做笔记。我们有一些来自莉莉·S、阿什利·希尔德雷斯和麦迪逊·巴顿的粉丝提问。珍娜，你真的写了笔记吗？如果是的话，你写了什么？我和你一样。我也想知道。我想，我了解我的死党，我猜你真的写了些东西。你在做什么？我在认真做笔记。我就知道。我就知道。
In character. Yeah. So there's a moment where I hold up my notebook and I tried to freeze on it to see if I could copy down what it said. And it was too fuzzy, but you can see that I am writing. Dwight did this. Dwight did that. Jim did this. I thought that the best way to get through those scenes was to actually write down what was happening around me as if I was in character. I figured you were. So you can see Michael is losing people. Stanley is so happy Phyllis dropped the egg. He's going to go sit down. He's going to do his crossword on his lawn chair. Creed wonders
符合角色。是的。所以有一个时刻我举起了我的笔记本，我试图把画面定格在那里，看看我能不能抄下上面写的内容。但它太模糊了，不过你能看出我确实在写。德怀特做了这个。德怀特做了那个。吉姆做了那个。我认为度过那些场景的最好方法就是真正写下我周围发生的事情，就好像我融入了角色一样。我猜你就是这么做的。所以你能看到迈克尔正在失去人心。斯坦利看到菲利斯把鸡蛋掉在地上，高兴极了。他要去坐下来。他要在他的草坪椅上做他的填字游戏。克里德溜达
off and in the background, we see him catch a fish with his bare hands. Yeah. Well, there's a really fun little tidbit about that on the DVD commentary. Harold said, you guys, this is how we did it. There was a rubber fish that they sort of submerged like in a bucket. What you can't see is this rubber fish in water in a bucket and they really were able to cheat it because Creed's a little bit over the hill, you know. Yeah. And he reaches down real fast and he pulls it out. But I thought Creed did a great job of selling that. That was some good hand acting.
开去，在背景里，我们看到他空手抓到了一条鱼。是的。嗯，DVD评论音轨里有一个关于这个的非常有趣的冷知识。哈罗德说，伙计们，我们是这样做的。有一条橡胶鱼，他们把它浸泡在一个桶里。你看不见的是水桶水里有这条橡胶鱼，他们确实能够作弊，因为克里德有点年事已高，你知道的。是的。他飞快地伸出手把它抽了出来。但我认为克里德在掩饰这一点上做得很好。那是一些很好的手部演技。
It was. And Harold said, true to Hollywood form, this gag, that rubber fish cost $500. Well, here's an interesting tidbit. Fishing is not allowed on Lake Scranton. Oh, that's true. But maybe if you're Creed and you grab it with your bare hands. Well, you know what that scene reminded me of, Angela? What? The edge. Oh, good Lord. Having to just get the fish. You got to. I mean, I don't know if anyone actually catches a fish with their hand in the edge, but I mean, that's survival. Maybe the bear did. The bear did. No, I won't bring up the bear. I know it's a trigger for you. I really think you need to watch the series alone about the survivalist in the woods because that's
确实如此。哈罗德说，符合好莱坞的风格，这个恶作剧，那条橡胶鱼花了500美元。嗯，这里有一个有趣的冷知识。斯克兰顿湖是不允许钓鱼的。哦，那是真的。但也许如果你是克里德，你空手抓住了它。嗯，你知道那个场景让我想起了什么吗，安吉拉？什么？荒野独居。哦，天哪。不得不去抓鱼。你必须去。我的意思是，我不知道是否有人真的在《荒野独居》里用手抓到鱼，但我的意思是，那是为了生存。也许那只熊抓到了。熊抓到了。不，我不会提起那只熊。我知道这是你的痛点。我真的觉得你需要独自观看关于树林里求生专家的系列节目，因为那就是
what it made me think of now. Hmm. Maybe I should. Okay. I'm currently really obsessed with The Chef Show. The Chef Show. The Chef Show. Okay. So John Favreau, who incidentally directed an episode of The Office in season nine, we'll get to it. Yeah. He has this movie called Chef and it's so good. It came out several years ago. It's one of my favorite movies. Well, he is obsessed with bread baking and cooking. And so he has started this series called The Chef Show where he goes and he interviews different chefs while they make their signature dishes. I can't get enough of it. You must love it. Now, this is a total tangent, but Isabel and I love the greatest British bake off. We love it so much. And
它现在让我想到的。嗯。也许我应该。好的。我目前真的迷上了《主厨秀》。《主厨秀》。《主厨秀》。好吧。所以乔恩·费儒，顺便说一句，他在第九季导演过一集《办公室》，我们以后会讲到。是的。他有一部电影叫《落魄大厨》，太棒了。它几年前上映的。这是我最喜欢的电影之一。嗯，他痴迷于烤面包和烹饪。所以他开始了这个名为《主厨秀》的系列节目，他去采访不同的厨师，同时他们制作他们的招牌菜。我简直看不够。你一定很喜欢。现在，这完全扯远了，但伊莎贝尔和我喜欢《英国烘焙大赛》。我们太喜欢了，而且
it's, it's, it checks off all my boxes. It's like in the beautiful English countryside. Yeah. And I just love, I love everything, like, especially when things don't go well. They'll say like, it's a bit of a disaster, wasn't it? Yes. Quite for the Paul. Yeah. I know. So matter of fact. I love that show as well. That show is the show that got me to start making bread. Oh, I didn't know that. Yeah. Yeah. That's my bread origin. Your bread origin story. My gosh, we are very off topic. We are very off topic. We have a lot to cover. We've got to get to this hot dog eating contest. Let's do it. We have a scene. Michael comes up to Pam and hands her 800 hot dogs that she needs to have ready in 10 minutes. What was
它，它符合我的所有要求。就像在美丽的英国乡村。是的。我就是喜欢，我喜欢一切，尤其是当事情不顺利的时候。他们会说，这有点像是一场灾难，不是吗？是的。对保罗来说相当……是的。我知道。太客观了。我也很喜欢那个节目。那个节目就是让我开始做面包的节目。哦，我不知道。是的。那是我的面包起源。你的面包起源故事。天哪，我们严重跑题了。我们严重跑题了。我们有很多内容要涵盖。我们得讲到这个热狗吃货大赛。我们开始吧。我们有一个场景。迈克尔走到帕姆面前，交给她800个热狗，要求她在10分钟内准备好。那是什么
Michael's budget for this day? I don't know. Where did he get the money for this? Just the 800 hot dogs alone. I know. How much does that cost? Can someone do some math on that? 800 hot dogs. I need to know how much money Michael spent on hot dogs. Well, also during that scene, and this is slightly off topic, but also not, we got some mail about it at 11 minutes, 27 seconds, you can see my bra strap. Oh, and a lot of people wanted to know why am I wearing a bra and a bathing suit? So here are my layers for the day, guys. I had on a bra because I like wearing them. That's why I have a bra on because I didn't want to wear just a flimsy swimming suit top. I like some support on top of the bra. I'm
迈克尔今天的预算是多少？我不知道。他从哪儿弄来的这笔钱？光是800根热狗。我知道。这得花多少钱？谁能算算这笔账？800根热狗。我想知道迈克尔在热狗上花了多少钱。好吧，在那场戏期间，这虽然有点题外话，但也不完全是，我们收到了一些关于它的邮件，在11分27秒时，你可以看到我的胸罩带。哦，很多人想知道为什么我穿着胸罩和泳衣？所以这是我当天的穿搭，伙计们。我穿了胸罩，因为我喜欢穿。这就是为什么我穿着胸罩，因为我不想只穿一件薄薄的泳衣上衣。我喜欢胸罩带来的一些支撑。我
wearing my wardrobe swimming suit top, which I loved because Carrie Bennett, she came up with this idea that if it was like a halter suit, we would get an indication of a bathing suit even though you never see me in the bathing suit. I thought it was a great idea. Then I have on a tank top and the reason I'm wearing the tank top is to cover up the bra strap. We had a little bit of a fail here at 11 minutes, 27 seconds. And then I'm wearing a hoodie. Those were my layers. So I guess somehow Pam cooked these hot dogs. I mean, she has a glance to camera where she's like, I don't know, maybe I didn't cook them. There is a deleted scene between Pam and Michael where she is grilling the hot dogs and he
穿着戏里的泳衣上衣，我很喜欢它，因为凯瑞·贝内特想出了这个主意，如果它是一件挂脖泳衣，我们就能看出这是一件泳衣，尽管你从未见我穿过这件泳衣。我觉得这是个好主意。然后我穿了一件背心，我穿背心的原因是为了遮住胸罩带。我们在11分27秒这里有点小失误。然后我穿着一件连帽衫。这些就是我的穿搭。所以我想潘不知怎么地烤了这些热狗。我的意思是，她对镜头瞥了一眼，好像在说，我不知道，也许我不是我烤的。潘和迈克尔之间有一段被删减的戏，她正在烤热狗，他
comes over and he's like, speed it up, Pam. Why aren't these done yet? And you're like, because there's 800 of them. Amazing. Amazing. So now it's time for the big hot dog eating contest. By the way, Michael takes credit for cooking up the hot dogs. I know, I know. And there is a wonderful deleted scene, Jenna. It wasn't scripted. It was a collective improv moment. When Michael says, dip it in the water so it will slide down your gullet more easily, our whole table said, that's what she said. I remember that.
走过来，对她说，快点，潘。这些怎么还没好？然后你会觉得，因为这里有800根。太棒了。太棒了。现在是举行盛大的吃热狗比赛的时候了。顺便说一句，迈克尔把烤热狗的功劳揽在自己身上。我知道，我知道。杰娜，这里有一段精彩的被删减的戏。这不是剧本里写的。这是大家集体即兴发挥的时刻。当迈克尔说，把它蘸在水里，这样它就更容易滑进你的食道时，我们全桌人都说，她就是这么说的。我记得那场戏。
And it didn't make it in, but it's so good. That's because that line from Steve was an improvisation. He, he in the script, he yells at Phyllis, dip it in the water, dip it in the water. But that's all that was scripted. So Steve in the moment added the, so it'll slide down your gullet faster. And then we all, we all said, how can you not, how can you not, how can you not? That was a layup. No, that was a softball. Isn't a layup and a softball sort of the same idea?
而且它没有被剪进正片里，但它太棒了。那是因为史蒂夫的这句台词是即兴发挥的。他在剧本里，他冲菲利斯大喊，把它蘸在水里，把它蘸在水里。但剧本里只有这些。所以史蒂夫当时临时加了句，这样它就能更快地滑进你的食道。然后我们所有人都，所有人都说，你怎么能不，你怎么能不，你怎么能不？那简直是个绝佳的机会。不，那是个简单的擦板球。上篮和擦板球难道不是同一个概念吗？
I don't know. A layup. After I've thought about it, I'm going to give this to softball because a softball involves more than one person, right? Yeah. So softball, one person sends a softball to another who then hits it out of the park. Whereas with a layup, it's, you do it on your own. You do it on your own. And I mean, a layup through a crowd is not easy to do if there's a bunch of guys in the paint. Let me throw some basketball at you. But maybe if you've
我不知道。上篮。我想了一下，我要把这个归功于垒球，因为垒球需要不止一个人参与，对吧？是的。所以垒球，一个人把球投给另一个人，然后那个人把球击出场外。而上篮，则是你自己完成的。你自己完成的。我的意思是，如果在有一群人的情况下带球上篮，如果内线有一堆人在，可并不容易做到。让我给你讲讲篮球。但也许如果你
got it. What are you talking about? What do you think a layup is? Hold on a second. Hold on a second. When's the last time you did a layup? I did one this week. What is it to you? A layup is when you dribble up to the basket and you put it in on your own. But I'm telling
明白了。你在说什么？你觉得什么是上篮？等一下。等一下。你上次上篮是什么时候？我这周刚上过。这关你什么事？上篮就是运球到篮筐下，然后自己把球放进去。但我告诉你
you, if you're doing a layup, you know, and you're, if you're doing a layup and you're being guarded, but then there's the breakaway layup, right? If you still the ball and you got the whole back of the court to yourself and you're like, yeah, and you do your layup and then sometimes you want to dunk on your layup. Hard for me because I'm five one. What's happening right now? I don't know. Where are we? What?
，如果你在上篮，你知道的，如果你在上篮时有人防守，但也有快攻上篮，对吧？如果你抢断了球，整个后场都只有你一个人，然后你大喊一声，yeah，你完成了上篮，有时候你还想在运球上篮时扣个篮。这对我来说很难，因为我身高只有一米五五。现在发生什么了？我不知道。我们在哪儿？什么？
Wait, do you watch basketball? Are you like a basketball fan? Where's all this lingo coming from? I played basketball. I played JV. And then when everyone got really tall, I had to stop playing because I was too short and we had a really good point guard. So then I became a basketball cheerleader and I was also the manager on the basketball team. And I was also a mascot one basketball season and I love basketball and we have a hoop in our driveway and we play all the time and I have a fantastic outside shot. And I often win at horse.
等等，你看篮球吗？你是篮球迷吗？这些行话都是从哪儿来的？我打过篮球。我打过初中校队。然后当所有人都变得很高时，我不得不停止打球，因为我太矮了，我们队有一个非常出色的控球后卫。于是我成了篮球啦啦队队长，我还是篮球队的经理。我甚至在一个篮球赛季里当过吉祥物，我热爱篮球，我们的车道上有一个篮筐，我们经常玩，我的远投非常厉害。而且我在“马”字投篮游戏里经常赢。
Angela, I'm clapping because people couldn't see me bowing down to you. But I mean, I'm speechless. I did not know this about you. And also I, I mean, I defer to you here. If this were a debate and someone had to win, you won. I mean, that was just, I want you to know it's not out yet, but I have this Advil commercial where I have to shoot baskets and I made like 13 baskets in a row and one of them they used in the actual shot. And I was so happy that they showed the whole shot. So I was like, I made that sucker. You were Brian Baumgartner while shooting the basketball episode. You have like a secret basketball skill that no one knew about.
安吉拉，我在鼓掌，因为大家看不到我向你顶礼膜拜。但我的意思是，我无言以对。我以前不知道你还有这技能。而且我也，我的意思是，在这方面我甘拜下风。如果这是一场辩论，必须分出胜负，你赢了。我的意思是，那简直是，我想让你知道这还没播，但我拍过一个雅维斯的广告，我得投篮，我连着投进了大概13个球，其中一个被用在了正片里。我太高兴了，因为他们展示了完整的投篮过程。所以我想，我把那个球投进了。你在拍摄篮球那集时简直就是布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳。你有一项谁都不知道的秘密篮球绝技。
Don't you remember the basketball hoop by our trailers and we would play horse? I was always out there with the guys playing horse. I do remember that and I have a picture of it. Yeah. Well, listen, I feel like we've gone off topic. You think? Wait, we're back to the hot dogs, guys. Back to the hot dogs. Andy wins the competition. But this was an arduous scene for everyone to shoot. I was really lucky, Jenna, because
你不记得我们拖车旁边的那个篮球框了吗，我们经常玩“马”字投篮游戏？我总是和男孩子们在那里玩“马”字投篮。我确实记得，我还有一张照片呢。好吧，听着，我觉得我们扯远了。你觉得呢？等等，我们说回热狗，伙计们。说回热狗。安迪赢了比赛。但对每个人来说，这都是一场艰难的拍摄。杰娜，我真的很幸运，因为
I said my character's a vegetarian. She's not going to be eating these. I made a really big plea about that. But poor Brian and Ed Leslie, all those guys were shoving hot dogs in their face. And Jenna, do you remember they were starting to gag? Do you remember that? Yeah. You know, we got a fan question from Caitlin Mulvihill who said, how many times did you have to film the hot dog contest scene and did you have to eat all the hot dogs every time? I just remember it took a long time. It was a lot of angles, a lot of coverage.
我说我的角色是个素食主义者。她才不会吃这些东西呢。我为此极力争取过。但可怜的布赖恩和埃德·莱斯利，所有这些家伙都在往嘴里塞热狗。杰娜，你还记得他们开始作呕了吗？你记得吗？记得。你知道的，我们收到了来自凯特琳·马尔维希尔的一个粉丝提问，她说，你拍摄吃热狗比赛的场景拍了多少次，每次你都得把所有的热狗都吃掉吗？我只记得这花了很长时间。有很多角度，很多镜头。
A lot of reaction shots. We were there for like half a day. Yeah. And Jen, we asked Jen, what was the hardest stunt during Beach Games? And this is what she had to say. I think the answer for what was the hardest stunt of this episode depends on who you ask. I think for the actors, it was possibly the hot dog eating contest. I'm curious what you guys think. I remember spit buckets. I couldn't be wrong about that, but I'm fairly certain there were a bunch of spit buckets, but there was some actual eating of hot dogs. And I think Ed Helms ate an enormous amount of hot dogs, if I remember correctly. I think he
很多反应镜头。我们在那儿待了大半天。是的。而且，杰娜，我们问过詹，海滩运动会期间最难的特技是什么？她是这么回答的。我觉得关于这一集最难特技是什么的答案取决于你问谁。我想对于演员来说，可能就是吃热狗比赛了。我很好奇你们觉得是什么。我记得有吐痰桶。我可能没记错，但我非常确信有很多吐痰桶，不过确实也真吃了一些热狗。而且如果我没记错的话，我觉得埃德·赫尔姆斯吃了数量惊人的热狗。我觉得他
was going really hard for winning the contest. So I think that that was probably a lot of people's answers. For me, it was getting the shot during the Michael Talking Head of Andy floating away at sea. Yes. We will get to that. She sent in some more amazing stuff about that stunt, but I do remember the spit buckets, Ange. I do too. And one of the things, you guys, on some shows, the way they shoot, you know when you're on camera and when you're off camera, you don't have to sort of participate. You can kind of not eat, right? But the way we shot this, there was a huge group shot,
为了赢得比赛真的很拼。所以我觉得这可能是很多人的答案。对我来说，是在迈克尔的采访镜头里捕捉安迪在海上漂走的画面。是的。我们会聊到那段的。她发来了一些关于那个特技的更精彩的内容，但我确实记得吐痰桶，安吉拉。我也记得。而且有一件事，伙计们，在某些节目中，他们的拍摄方式是，你知道什么时候你在镜头前，什么时候你不在镜头前，你不必非得参与。你可以不用吃，对吧？但我们拍摄的方式是，有一个超大的群体镜头，
right? There's a camera that's capturing everything. So these guys had to eat on every take because they never knew when the camera was specifically on them or not. And I remember when they would yell cut immediately, like the prop guys would run over with buckets and these guys would all start spitting in the buckets because they couldn't have the buckets on the ground. There was nowhere to hide them, right? And so the prop guys would run over with the buckets and Ed set this thing in the DVD commentary. He said, first of all, spitting out food that I've been chewing and holding in my mouth. The action of spitting out this chewed food would activate my gag reflex. So I'd start gagging.
对吧？有一个镜头捕捉着一切。所以这些家伙在每一个镜头里都必须吃，因为他们永远不知道镜头什么时候专门对着他们。我记得当导演大喊“卡”时，道具师会立刻拿着桶跑过去，然后这些家伙就会开始往桶里吐东西，因为他们不能把桶放在地上。没地方藏，对吧？所以道具师会拿着桶跑过来，埃德在DVD评论音轨里说过这件事。他说，首先，吐出我一直在咀嚼并含在嘴里的食物。吐出这些咀嚼过的食物这个动作会触发我的呕吐反射。所以我开始作呕。
And he said, but then on top of that, this bucket that they would bring around, several other people had spit their food out into. He said, just all of it, all of it. He said, like, they were all getting so grossed out. Well, this scene really reminded me of that birthday cake scene from Meredith's birthday where we all ate chocolate chip ice cream cake. I can't eat it to this day. I can't eat it. Same. We ate so much of it because we never knew when we were on camera. And then like that, I feel like there's barely any footage in this episode of these guys eating the hot dogs. It does not accurately reflect how much hot dog eating happened.
他说，但不仅如此，他们拿过来的这个桶里，其他好几个人也把食物吐进去了。他说，总之所有这些，所有这些。他说，就好像，他们所有人都恶心坏了。好吧，这个场景真的让我想起了梅雷迪思生日时那个吃纸杯蛋糕的场景，当时我们都吃了巧克力芯片冰激凌蛋糕。直到今天我都吃不下它。我也吃不下。一样。我们吃了太多，因为我们永远不知道什么时候在镜头前。然后就像那样，我觉得这一集里几乎没有什么这些家伙吃热狗的镜头。这并不能准确反映出他们到底吃了多少热狗。
Not at all. These poor guys. And Jim isn't eating the hot dogs. There's a deleted scene where he brought a tuna salad and he is not even participating. So John did not have to do this. And neither did I. And neither did Steve. Oh, God. Well, Jenna, so Andy wins with 13 hot dogs, right? Mm hmm. Mm hmm. I just looked up this year, the hot dog eating contest, the Nathan's hot dog eating contest for 2020. Oh, lady. Did you too? Did you too? Because I've been to the hot dog eating contest. What? Yeah. In 2011. What? How? I went to Coney Island. Lee and I were in New York. We were looking for something to do over July 4th weekend. And you went to it? We saw that the Coney Island hot dog eating, we got on
一点也不。这群可怜的家伙。吉姆没有吃热狗。有一个被删减的场景，他带了一份金枪鱼沙拉，他甚至都没有参与。所以约翰不需要这么做。我也不需要。史蒂夫也不需要。哦，天哪。好吧，杰娜，安迪吃了13个热狗赢了，对吧？嗯嗯。嗯嗯。我刚刚查了一下今年的吃热狗大赛，2020年内森吃热狗大赛。哦，天哪。你也是吗？你也是吗？因为我去过吃热狗大赛。什么？对。在2011年。什么？怎么去的？我去了康尼岛。我和李当时在纽约。我们在国庆周末找点事情做。然后你就去了？我们看到康尼岛吃热狗大赛，我们上了
the subway and we rode it out there. I was very pregnant. I was like seven months pregnant. Oh, my gosh. I did not know any of this. See, you think you know your best friend. And then all of a sudden she's going to hot dog eating contest and she knows how to play basketball. Yeah, exactly. And I, here's my memory. It was super exciting. We only saw the men's contest. I saw Joey Chestnut win the hot dog eating contest. He won again this year. Yeah. And he broke his world record this year. His nickname is Jaws. Joey Jaws Chestnut. Yeah. This year, because we both looked it up, Joey Chestnut ate 75 hot dogs and buns in 10 minutes. And Jenna in the female category, Miki Pseudo ate 48 and a half hot dogs in 10 minutes and
地铁，坐车去了那里。我当时怀孕很明显。我怀孕大概七个月了。哦，天哪。我完全不知道这些。你看，你以为你很了解你最好的朋友。结果突然之间她去参加吃热狗比赛，她还知道怎么打篮球。没错，完全是这样。而且我，这是我的记忆。这超级令人兴奋。我们只看了男子组的比赛。我看到乔伊·切斯纳特赢了吃热狗大赛。他今年又赢了。对。而且他今年打破了自己的世界纪录。他的绰号是“大白鲨”。乔伊·“大白鲨”·切斯纳特。是的。今年，因为我们俩都查了，乔伊·切斯纳特在10分钟内吃掉了75个热狗和面包，而在女子组方面，杰娜，米基·苏多在10分钟内吃掉了48.5个热狗，
now has the new world record. Yeah. Joey Chestnut has won every year since 2007, with the exception of one year in 2015, Matt Stoney won. But Joey has won every year since and Miki has won every year since 2014. I will say one thing. When I went to the hot dog eating contest, I mentioned I was very pregnant. I had to pee and there were no restrooms and all of the businesses, because they're such a giant influx of people that come down, they all have signs that say no public restroom, no public restroom, no public restroom. You can't just go in and use their bathroom. But I found an employee at the Dunkin Donuts who sneaked me in and let me use the bathroom there. Bless them. And I still to this day
现在创造了新的世界纪录。是的。自2007年以来，除了2015年马特·斯通尼赢过一年外，乔伊·切斯纳特每年都赢，而米基自2014年以来每年都赢。我要说一件事。我去吃热狗大赛的时候，我提到过我当时怀孕很明显。我想上厕所，但那里没有洗手间，所有的商家，因为涌入了大量的人潮，都挂着“无公共厕所”、“无公共厕所”、“无公共厕所”的牌子。你不能随便进去用他们的洗手间。但我找到了唐恩都乐的一名员工，他把我偷偷带进去，让我用了那里的洗手间。感谢他们。直到今天我
want to say thank you so much for helping me relieve my pregnant bladder that day. Thank you nice person at Dunkin Donuts on Coney Island in 2011. You know, if you were Meredith, like the deleted scene, you would have just gone and squat in the bushes right by the West. Oh no. Poor Kate. Kate in this episode. Oh my God. Well, maybe Angela on that note, we should take a break here and both use the restroom. And then we'll come back with some sabotage sandwich. Now I said sandwich earlier. This time I'm saying sabotage. Okay, we are back. And oh, Angela, I love this scene so much. I rewound it and watched it twice. I do love this scene. It's one of my favorites. So this is the scene where Dwight and Angela
还想说，非常感谢你那天帮我这个怀孕的膀胱解围。谢谢2011年康尼岛唐恩都乐的好心人。你知道的，如果你是梅雷迪思，就像被删减的场景里那样，你就会直接去西边树丛里蹲着了。哦，不。可怜的凯特。凯特这一集太惨了。哦，天哪。好吧，安吉拉，既然说到这儿，我们是不是该在这里休息一下，俩人都去上个洗手间。然后我们回来聊聊“破坏三明治”。我刚才说的是三明治。这次我要说的是“破坏”。好吧，我们回来了。哦，安吉拉，我太喜欢这个场景了。我倒回去看了两遍。我真的很喜欢这个场景。这是我最喜欢的场景之一。这是德怀特和安吉拉
have tiptoed away from the group. And they're having a private conversation about sabotage. Dwight would like Angela to sabotage her team. Yes, the ancient art like Dutch sabotage. I was like, what? This scene was so fun to film. First of all, I remember Jen and Harold and Rain and I trying to figure out where Dwight and I would be where it would really look like we were away from everyone. And also that we would think that we got away with it, right? Yes. And that the spy shot would have to be far enough away. So we did sort of climb. There were these little sand dunes, Jenna, do you remember? They were sort of small and they had like big sort of like tall kind of grass growing out of them. Yeah,
从人群中悄悄溜走的场景。他们正在进行一场关于破坏的私密对话。德怀特希望安吉拉破坏她所在的团队。是的，这是一种古老的艺术，就像荷兰人的破坏行为。我当时想，什么？拍摄这个场景太有趣了。首先，我记得杰娜、哈罗德、雷恩和我试图弄清楚我和德怀特应该在哪里，才能看起来真的离所有人很远。而且还要让我们觉得我们成功溜掉了，对吧？是的。而且偷拍的镜头必须距离足够远。所以我们确实爬了一段。杰娜，你还记得吗，那里有一些小沙丘？它们有点小，上面长着大片大片那种高高的草。对，
like reedy grass coming out of them. Itchy. Itchy, reedy grass. Like it kind of like remember it. It kind of cut you a little if it touched your skin. But we sort of tucked back in there for this scene. And there are some great bloopers and it's mostly just me laughing because I could not get through it. When he said sabotage and I said sandwich every single time, the absurdity of these two, not to mention, I could hear Jen Slotta laughing from her little group of bushes where her and Harold were hiding. And I would be like, Jen, stop laughing. I just got it together. And now Jen is laughing. And you couldn't see her. It was just like this little clump of bushes that was like, Oh my gosh, I love
就像那种长出来的芦苇草。扎人。扎人的、芦苇般的草。如果碰到皮肤，会有点像割破的那种感觉。但我们为了这个场景，确实往里面钻了钻。这里有一些非常棒的搞笑花絮，大部分都是我在笑，因为我实在拍不下去。当他说破坏，而我每次都说三明治时，这两个人的荒谬感，更不用说，我能听到杰娜·斯洛塔在她和哈罗德藏身的那个小树丛里笑的声音。我会说，杰娜，别笑了。我好不容易才调整好状态。现在杰娜又在笑了。而且你还看不到她。就好像是那一小丛灌木，就觉得，哦天哪，我太喜欢了。
it so much. I love the end when Dwight says if Michael organizes a group hug stand next to me. Jen told me she loved writing for Dwight and Angela that she loved their sort of suppressed love for one another. Yeah. Oh, it's such a good scene. Such a good scene. One thing about the scene that made it tricky that you might not think of is that this is one of the few times where Dwight and I have to be standing facing one another and you really see our height difference. I knew it was a wide shot because it was a spy shot. But now it makes me think it was also that wide to fit you both in frame. Yes. And the other thing, the other thing to point out, which I thought was really great is you can really
我太喜欢最后德怀特说如果迈克尔组织集体拥抱就站在我身边的那句话了。杰娜告诉我她很喜欢为德怀特和安吉拉写剧本，她很喜欢他们那种对彼此压抑的爱。哦，这真是一场好戏。太棒的戏了。这个场景有一个让它变得棘手的地方，你可能不会想到，这是德怀特和我少有的几次必须面对面站着的时候，你真的能看出我们的身高差。我知道这是一个广角镜头，因为这是一个偷拍镜头。但现在让我想这也同样是为了把你们俩都拍进画面里。是的。还有一件事，要指出的是，我觉得真的很棒，你能清楚地
see that Dwight is wearing a Cooper Seafood T-shirt. Hey, local Scranton reference there. I know. Well, next up is the sumo competition. Oh my goodness, Jenna. Where to begin? Where to begin? Where to begin? I'll tell you, I did one of those like a guffaw. Is that the word where you laugh out loud like it just like it takes over your body and you can't even suppress it? When I saw John in his little toothpick legs walk out in that sumo suit. Look at his legs. If you haven't, look at his tiny little legs sticking out of that sumo suit in his little head popping up. It made me laugh so hard. Now, I know that those guys were just so hot in those suits. Oh, yeah. They were dying and we had these little
看到德怀特穿着一件库珀海鲜店的T恤。嘿，那里有个斯克兰顿的本地梗。我懂。好吧，接下来是相扑比赛。哦天哪，杰娜。从何说起？从何说起？从何说起？我跟你说，我当时发出了一声狂笑。是那种哈哈大笑的词吗，就像它掌控了你的身体，你甚至无法压抑它？当我看到约翰穿着那套相扑服、迈着他那牙签般的小细腿走出来时。看看他的腿。如果你还没看过，看看他从相扑服里伸出来的、细胳膊细腿的小细腿，还有他那颗探出来的小脑袋。把我笑得不行。现在我知道那些家伙在那些衣服里热得不行。哦，是的。他们快热死了，我们还有这些小
fans that they would try to like cool them off with. But I'm sure that they were just so sweaty, but they also had the best time in those. They were like, they all turned into children and they were loving it. I have to say. They couldn't wait to run at each other and like throw themselves at each other and all of it. They were having so much fun. But I do remember between takes, they could not sit down. Yes. They could not sit down and people would run over with like little umbrellas and these fans to try to cool them off. And Jenna, I was hanging out with rain and I have this great photo that one of the things I loved is that I could lean on rain's belly like I had something to prop myself
电风扇，他们试图用这些来给他们降温。但我敢肯定他们身上全是汗，不过他们在里面也玩得最开心。他们就像，所有人都变成了小孩子，他们玩得很开心。我必须得说。他们迫不及待地朝彼此跑去，把彼此扑倒在地，诸如此类。他们玩得太开心了。但我确实记得在拍摄间隙，他们根本坐不下来。是的。他们坐不下来，人们会拿着小伞和这些风扇跑过去试图给他们降温。而且，杰娜，我和雷恩待在一起，我有一张很棒的照片，我最喜欢的一点是，我可以靠在雷恩的肚子上，就像我有什么东西可以支撑自己
up on. So I have this photo and it's him and I casually talking, but I'm resting myself on his sumo belly. That's incredible. Well, we had a fan question from Freya McKenzie and Jesse Magison. Is it true that rain Wilson actually put Leslie David Baker in the hospital while shooting beach games? Yes. What happened was that during all this sumo wrestling, Leslie got sand in his eyes and they tried to flush it out, but they couldn't. And I remember he had to leave set. And I don't know if he went to the hospital or to an eye doctor, but he had a scratched cornea. Yeah, I thought they took him to a local, like the clinic, the nearest hospital. Every single day when you're filming, whether it's on set or location,
一样。所以我有了这张照片，照片里我和他在随便聊天，但我把身体靠在他的相扑肚子上。这太不可思议了。好吧，我们收到了来自弗雷娅·麦肯齐和杰西·马吉森的粉丝提问。雷恩·威尔逊在拍摄《海滩运动会》时真的把莱斯利·大卫·贝克送进医院了吗？是的。情况是这样的，在所有这些相扑摔跤的过程中，莱斯利眼睛里进了沙子，他们试图把它冲洗出来，但没能成功。我记得他不得不离开片场。我不知道他是去了医院还是眼科医生那里，但他角膜擦伤了。是的，我以为他们带他去了当地的一个诊所，最近的医院。每天你在拍摄时，无论是在片场还是外景地，
they put in the call sheet, the location where you're filming and the nearest hospital's location. Yeah. So they researched that ahead of time for this reason. So I think they took him to the nearest whatever that was clinic, right? Yeah. And he was in quite a bit of pain and he was like, no, it's still in there. There's something wrong. You know that moment in your body where you're like, it's not right. Something's not right. And it had in fact, scratched his cornea and they treated him. And then he came back and finished filming because he's such a trooper. Well, I've had this happen to me, Angela. I got a piece of sand in my eye by using a face scrub. Oh, Lord. Sand in it. And I got a piece in my eye and
他们都会在通告单上写明你拍摄的地点和最近的医院的位置。是的。所以他们出于这个原因提前做好了调查。所以我猜他们把他带到了最近的诊所，无论那是哪里，对吧？是的。而且他非常痛苦，他一直在说，不，它还在里面。有什么东西不对劲。你知道身体里那种感觉，你会觉得，这不对劲。有什么地方不对劲。事实上，他的角膜被擦伤了，他们为他进行了治疗。然后他又回来完成了拍摄，因为他太敬业了。好吧，安吉拉，我也遇到过这种事。我用洗面奶洗脸时，眼里进了一粒沙子。哦，天哪。里面有沙子。我的眼睛里进了一粒沙子，
I was like, it feels like something's in your eye when you scratch your cornea, but I couldn't find it. So I went to an eye doctor and I had scratched my cornea. So I feel for Leslie, it is a very, it is a not fun feeling. I have never scratched my cornea, but one time I was eating jalapeno potato chips because I love them so much. And I bit into it kind of aggressively and the jalapeno dust off the chip went into my eyes and it was very painful. Why are you laughing? That's really happened. I bit into the chip and then I was like, why am I laughing? How could you listen to that story and not laugh? I don't know. Okay, we should probably get back on topic. Yeah. Well, here's the thing. I remember
然后我觉得，当你的角膜擦伤时，感觉就像有什么东西进了眼睛，但我找来找去找不到。所以我去了眼科医生那里，发现我的角膜擦伤了。所以我对莱斯利感同身受，这真的是一种非常不好的感觉。我从来没有擦伤过角膜，但有一次我在吃墨西哥胡椒薯片，因为我太喜欢它们了。我有点用力地咬了一口，薯片上的墨西哥胡椒粉末飞进了我的眼睛里，非常痛苦。你笑什么？这真的发生了。我咬了一口薯片，然后我想，我为什么在笑？你怎么能听完这个故事而不笑呢？我不知道。好吧，我们大概应该说回正题了。好吧，事情是这样的。我记得
Leslie leaving set, but I don't remember when exactly it happened or how it happened. I just know he got sand in his eye. All right. This is what I think happened. I watched the deleted scenes and there's a moment. It's not in the episode where Dwight is wrestling with Stanley and knocks him to the ground and is like, take that old man. And he kind of kicks at the sand, right? Oh, yes. I remember this. And I think then rain felt really bad because he realized in that moment, that's when we thought it happened. Yes. That's right. That's right. Well, this was not the only injury from this episode. Ed hurt his finger during the sumo wrestling. Do you remember that? I think he like lost a fingernail or
莱斯利离开了片场，但我不记得具体是什么时候发生的，或者它是怎么发生的。我只知道他眼里进了沙子。好吧。我觉得事情是这样的。我看了被删减的场景，有一个片段。正片里没有，德怀特和斯坦利摔跤，把他撞倒在地，然后说，尝尝这个吧，老家伙。然后他踢了踢沙子，对吧？哦，是的。我记得这个。然后我觉得雷恩当时觉得很糟糕，因为他意识到就在那一刻，我们觉得事情就是那时候发生的。没错。就是这样。好吧，这一集里受伤的不止这一个。埃德在相扑摔跤时弄伤了手指。你记得吗？我记得他好像掉了一片指甲还是
something. He was like, sorry, it makes me laugh so hard. I shouldn't laugh, but it's when that moment, if you guys watch it, when Andy and Dwight really start going at each other like Dwight walks over and he's eating a sandwich, even though he's eating all these hot dogs. He walks over and then they just start going at each other and Ed is like kind of flailing his arms at him. Somehow in this tussle, Ed broke his fingernail, but he said he broke it really bad. Like it ripped. I think it like ripped below the. That's what I remember. Yeah. It was gruesome looking. It was gruesome. But Ed was like yelling in his sumo shirt. He was yelling, stop, stop. And all he could get out was I broke my nail
什么的。他当时说，对不起，这把我笑得太厉害了。我不该笑，但就是那个时刻，如果你们看的话，当安迪和德怀特真正开始对打时，就像德怀特走过去吃着三明治，尽管他一直在吃那些热狗。他走过去，然后他们就开始扭打在一起，埃德有点像在朝他挥舞手臂。不知怎么的，在这场拉扯中，埃德弄断了他的指甲，但他后来说他断得很厉害。就像裂开了一样。我记得好像是。是的。看起来很吓人。很吓人。但埃德穿着他的相扑服在大喊。他大喊，停下，停下。他只能喊出我弄断了指甲，
and people were like, okay, did you break your fingernail? He's like, no guys, I broke my nail. Oh no. Oh no. But he didn't leave set. No, he didn't leave set. They came over and they, but there was that moment when someone was like, what happened? Like Ed broke his nail and he's like, no, it's more than just a broken nail. And then they, they wrapped it up. Well, now Angela, we're going to get into a big moment. This was huge for our show. This is a huge stunt. You were, you have to remember our show never left a little tiny office. So we've got a breakdown. We've got two big things coming up. We've got this Andy floating away and then the coals. So Jenna, let's start with Andy. Okay. Andy walks
然后人们就问，怎么了？就像埃德弄断了指甲，然后他说，不，伙计们，这不仅仅是断了指甲。然后他们，他们把伤口包扎了一下。好吧，现在安吉拉，我们要进入一个重要时刻了。这对我们的节目来说意义重大。这是一个重大的特技。你得记住，我们的节目从来没有离开过那个小小的办公室。所以我们要拍拆分镜头。我们要迎来两件大事。一个是安迪漂走，另一个是煤炭。所以，杰娜，我们从安迪开始吧。好的。安迪走
over to the water and we had a fan question about this from Ali Jo Higginbotham who said, when Andy walks to the lake, he has something yellow in his hand. What is he holding and what is he planning to do with it at the shore? Well, he's holding a bandana. He's holding a yellow bandana. Michael had handed these out in the egg race. And that's what everyone had used to cover their eyes. And Andy is holding his yellow bandana from the egg race. And he's going to, he hopes to dip it in the water to then maybe wrap it around his neck to cool himself off. This was the idea. Yes. But instead he falls in the water and starts floating away. When he fell in the water, you know, I wasn't too far off because my
到水边，我们收到了阿里·乔·希金博瑟姆关于这个的粉丝提问，她说，当安迪走向湖边时，他手里拿著黄色的东西。他拿的是什么，他打算在岸边用它做什么？好吧，他拿的是一根头巾。他拿着一根黄色的头巾。迈克尔在运鸡蛋比赛中发过这些。那是每个人都用来蒙住眼睛的东西。安迪拿的是他在运鸡蛋比赛中用过的黄色头巾。他打算，他希望能把它浸在水里，然后也许把它缠在脖子上给自己降温。这就是他的想法。是的。但相反，他掉进水里，开始漂走了。当他掉进水里时，你知道的，我离得不远，因为我的
character witnesses this. Yes. And there's a take that didn't make it that he literally went, he like rolled Jenna, rolled into the water, but they used this take because it was more clear why he was going down there. He's trying to, trying to hang that bandana in the water, trying to balance. Well, let me say, and we got another frequently asked question from Candace Kelso, Michael Loong, Olive Taylor and Phoebe Bono. Was that really Ed in the water? Or was that a stunt double? Guys, that was Ed in the water. Ed did it all. I don't know that they offered him a stunt double. I don't know. Kent told me they offered him a stunt double, but Ed insisted on doing all of the floating in the water
角色目睹了这一切。是的。有一个没有被采用的镜头，他 literalmente，他像滚一样，杰娜，滚进了水里，但他们采用了现在这个镜头，因为这样更清楚他为什么要走到那下面去。他试图，试图把那块头巾浸在水里，试图保持平衡。好吧，让我说说，我们收到了坎迪斯·凯尔索、迈克尔·隆、奥利弗·泰勒和菲比·博诺提出的另一个常见问题。那真的是埃德在水里吗？还是替身？伙计们，那真的是埃德在水里。埃德亲自完成了这一切。我不知道他们是否给他提供过替身。我不知道。肯告诉我他们给他提供过替身，但埃德坚持要自己完成所有在水里漂浮的戏份
himself. He was out there floating for over 45 minutes. And I'm thinking, maybe when he was like, Oh no, I'll fall in the water. Like maybe he didn't realize what that all entailed. Yeah. And perhaps having a stunt double on the side to complete some of the very far away floating. But guys, that is Ed the whole time floating out there. Not only in the day, but then he had to do it again at night. This was two different shoots for him in the water, a day scene and a night scene. Now, when he was out there at night, he did have a thin wetsuit on underneath all that sumo gear to keep him warm. So they did think of that. But before we get too far into the stunt, Angela, we also had fan questions
。他在水里漂了45分钟以上。我在想，也许当他觉得，哦不，我会掉进水里。就好像他可能没有意识到这需要付出什么。是的。也许在旁边准备一个替身来完成一些距离非常远的漂浮镜头会更好。但伙计们，从头到尾在水里漂浮的都是埃德。不仅是白天，他晚上还得再拍一次。这对他在水里来说是两场不同的拍摄，一场日景戏和一场夜景戏。现在，当他晚上在外面时，他在所有那些相扑装备下面确实穿了一件薄薄的潜水服来保暖。所以他们确实考虑到了这一点。但在我们在特技方面深入探讨之前，安吉拉，我们还收到了来自
from Rebecca Gonzalez, Connor N and Maura Anderson, who said, Angela, how did you make it through the scene of Andy floating away? It was so hard. It was that's what she said. Oh boy. I'm sorry. It was really, it was really difficult. Difficult not to laugh. Really difficult, especially because Ed was improvising a little bit as he floated away. Some of that dialogue was not scripted. So, you know, when I'm like, I don't really understand what it is you're saying to me, that was scripted. But then Ed, Ed was physically floating away and he was dealing with the elements and he improvised this line. Look at what I'm doing and go tell somebody it. I love that line so much. That was Ed improvising. That is
丽贝卡·冈萨雷斯、康纳·N和莫拉·安德森的粉丝提问，他们说，安吉拉，你是怎么忍住不笑拍完安迪漂走的场景的？太难了。那就是她说的。哦，天哪。我很抱歉。真的太难了。很难忍住不笑，尤其是因为埃德在漂走的时候还即兴发挥了一点。有些台词不是剧本里写的。所以，你知道的，当我说，我真的听不懂你在对我说什么，那是剧本里写的。但接着埃德，埃德真的在水里漂走，他还要应对水里的环境，他即兴说出了这句台词。看看我在做什么，去告诉别人。我太喜欢这句台词了。那是埃德即兴发挥的。这太
awesome. I know. So it was really hard. And I didn't want to laugh because poor Ed is floating out in that water. You know what I mean? Like, yes, if you laugh, you ruin that moment and he has to float longer. I was working hard. I was working hard, not to laugh. Well, we asked Jen about Ed in the water and here's what she had to say. Oh, shooting the Andy floating away scenes was really fun. I love that part of the script. I love when Angela pretends that she doesn't understand what he's saying. That was so much fun to write. I remember that Ed was like in the sumo suit and then there was a rope
棒了。我知道。所以这真的很难。我不想笑，因为可怜的埃德正漂在那片水里呢。你知道我的意思吗？就像，对吧，如果你笑了，你就毁了那个时刻，他就得在水里多漂一会儿。我很努力。我很努力不笑。好吧，我们问了詹关于埃德在水里的事，她是这么说的。哦，拍摄安迪漂走的场景真的很有趣。我喜欢剧本里的那部分。我喜欢安吉拉假装听不懂他在说什么。写那段真的太有趣了。我记得埃德穿着相扑服，然后有一根绳子
attached to him and he was being pulled by a boat and then at a certain point the boat would leave him and then he would just drift. But there was also a current. I believe the water was also cold and he had to keep his head up. And I remember that it was a challenging thing because his head would sort of get lost and it would just like go under unless he helped. He put his neck up and just try to hold it up. So I think it was a difficult thing. Also the timing of the boat and the timing was trying to get it on camera with Michael's talking head was difficult. So I remember that Ed was like a real trooper and there were a lot of discussions about like how far out he should be at sea because
系在他身上，他被一艘船拉着，然后在某个时刻船会离开他，然后他就会任由水流漂走。但当时还有水流。我相信水也很冷，他必须把头抬起来。我记得这是一件极具挑战性的事情，因为他的头会有点迷失方向，如果不帮忙的话就会沉下去。他把脖子抬起来，努力把头撑住。所以我认为这是一件很困难的事情。还有船的时间安排以及试图把它和迈克尔的采访镜头结合起来的时间安排也很困难。所以我记得埃德就像一个真正的勇士，关于他应该在海里漂得多远，有过很多讨论，因为
we wanted to see him. We didn't want to be too obvious that it was him and Michael might see him, but we didn't want him to be so far away that he was this tiny little dot. So Ed was in the water for quite a while while we tried to work this out. And the other thing I remember, which is crazy to say now, but there was a safety meeting right before it and I feel like the very beginning of the safety meeting like Ed was there, but like he was just getting there because everything was so rushed. And I think the safety person said one thing like as Ed was approaching that I wasn't sure Ed clocked and I had this moment of should I tell him or not? And I remember the safety guy talking about water
我们需要看到他。我们不想太明显地看出那是他，迈克尔可能会看到他，但我们又不想让他离得太远，以至于他只是个小小的黑点。所以我们在尝试解决这个问题的时候，埃德在水里待了相当长的时间。我记得的另一件事，现在说起来觉得很疯狂，但在拍摄前开了一个安全会议，我觉得在安全会议刚开始的时候，埃德在那里，但他就像是刚刚赶到，因为一切都太仓促了。而且我想安全员在埃德靠近的时候说了一件事，我不确定埃德有没有听进去，我有过这样一个瞬间：我是不是该告诉他？我记得安全员谈到了
snakes and I was like, oh my God, oh my God, do I repeat this dead? Do I not repeat this dead? I don't think I repeated it to Ed because he was going to be in this water. It was going to be very cold. I thought, would I want to know about water snakes before I got into the water in a sumo suit or not? So yeah, I think I made that decision. Tell me if you think that was the correct decision to make. Anyway, there were a lot of challenges of shooting that there were no snake events during the shooting of that sequence. And I thought Ed did a phenomenal job. And so did Angela. And I'm just in love with that sequence of events. But it was challenging to shoot. Wow. Ed, Ed, possibility of water snakes. Oh
水蛇，然后我想，哦天哪，哦天哪，我要把这个重复给埃德听吗？我不要重复给埃德听？我想我没有把它重复给埃德听，因为他马上要下水了。水会非常冷。我想，在我穿着相扑服下水之前，我会想知道水蛇的事吗？所以，是的，我想我做出了那个决定。告诉我你认为这是不是正确的决定。不管怎样，拍摄那个序列时有很多挑战，拍摄期间没有发生水蛇事件。我觉得埃德的表现棒极了。安吉拉也是。我简直太喜欢那个事件序列了。但拍摄起来确实很有挑战性。哇。埃德，埃德，遇到水蛇的可能性。哦
my God. Oh boy. Jen Salada. Well, now Jen mentioned in her clip that they would have to pull Ed behind a boat to get him in place. So Kent told me that power boats were not allowed on the lake. So they had to have a stunt coordinator in a rowboat. I remember, Jenna, I remember rowing him. Yeah. Can you imagine if you're somewhere else at this park and you're just hiking or maybe you're riding a horse from the equestrian center and you look out onto the lake and you see a man in a rowboat rowing another man by a rope who's in a sumo suit. What are you thinking when you see that? I don't know. What goes to your head? I don't know. I don't know. Are you worried? What are you thinking? So
天哪。哦，男孩。詹·斯洛塔。好吧，现在詹在她的片段中提到，他们必须把埃德拉在一艘船后面来把他带到指定位置。所以肯告诉我，湖里是不允许开动力艇的。所以他们必须让一个特技协调员坐在划艇里。我记得，杰娜，我记得划船拉他。是的。你能想象如果你在这个公园的某个地方，你只是在远足，或者也许你正在马术中心骑着马，你望向湖面，看到一个男人在划船，用一根绳子拉着另一个穿着相扑服的男人。当你看到这一幕时你在想什么？我不知道。你脑子里在想什么？我不知道。我不知道。你在担心吗？你在想什么？所以
I watched this play out because we would have to reset Ed to that spot where we would have dialogue and inevitably he'd float away, right? And then they would, the guy, there he was. And I had to make sure I didn't look at the rowboat guy, right? You know, like I couldn't have my eyes dart away. But off in the periphery of my vision was this guy in a boat and he would row and pull Ed. Ed had a harness suit on under the sumo suit and they put through the arm of this sumo suit a fishing line. Yeah. And this guy would pull Ed and as he did, Jenna, I would see water break around his body, you know, like if you hold something in the water. Yeah. And Ed said that a majority of that water
我看着这一切上演，因为我们得把埃德重新安置到那个我们要进行对话的地点，而他不可避免地会漂走，对吧？然后他们会，那个人，他就坐在那儿。我得确保我没有看那个划船的家伙，对吧？你知道的，我的视线不能飘走。但在我视野的余光里，这个家伙坐在船里划着拉着埃德。埃德在相扑服里面穿着一套威亚衣，他们把一根钓鱼线穿过这个相扑服的袖子。是的。这个家伙拉着埃德，当他这么做时，杰娜，我会看到水流在他身体周围分开，你知道的，就像你在水里抓着什么东西一样。是的。埃德说，大部分水
as he was being pulled would flush through the suit. Oh my God. And out his neck. Well, I can't told me if you look carefully in the Michael talking head where Ed is floating in the background, you will see that there's a pretty strong current in the water, but Ed is not moving. That is because at that point, the only way to keep him in the shot was to just keep him attached to the boat. And so he said, if you look for it, he's very oddly staying in one place while a pretty heavy current is going underneath him. So, so insane. Angela, I also got the story about these sumo suits from Carrie Bennett, our wardrobe designer. Oh, let's hear it. So she said that this was one of the most difficult costume
在他被拉着的时候会冲进这套衣服里。哦，天哪。然后从他的脖子处冲出来。好吧，肯告诉我，如果你仔细看迈克尔的采访镜头，背景里埃德在漂浮，你会发现水里的水流相当湍急，但埃德并没有动。那是因为在那一点上，让他留在镜头里的唯一方法就是把他一直拴在船上。所以他说，如果你仔细找找，他非常奇怪地停在同一个地方，而一股相当强劲的水流正在他身下流过。所以，太疯狂了。安吉拉，我还从我们的服装设计师凯瑞·贝内特那里听到了关于这些相扑服的故事。哦，说来听听。所以她说这是她为我们的节目设计过的最困难的服装挑战之一。
challenges she had for our show. She had to create these inflatable sumo suits. But because she knew Andy would end up floating away in it, whatever she put them in had to be safe for him to float on water. So she said, as soon as she read the script, she immediately went to Greg and said, I cannot design a costume that will allow someone to float on water. I need a stunt person to help me. So she got together with the stunt person and they realized that kind of like what Jen said, the biggest challenge was keeping his head from going underwater because she was like, his body would float, but the head would go under. So that is why the guys are wearing those crazy headpieces in the episode. Those
她必须制作这些可充气的相扑服。但因为她知道安迪最后会穿着它在水里漂走，她让他穿的任何东西都必须保证他在水面上漂浮的安全。所以她说，她一读完剧本，就立刻去找格雷格说，我设计不出一套能让人在水面上漂浮的服装。我需要一个特技人员来帮我。于是她和特技人员聚在一起，他们意识到，就像詹说的那样，最大的挑战是防止他的头沉入水下，因为她说，他的身体会漂浮，但头会沉下去。这就是为什么这些家伙在这一集中戴着那些奇怪的头饰。那些
were custom made, right? Yes. Yeah. She said, what if I made a floaty helmet in the shape of like a sumo wrestler's bun? And the bun is actually a floating device. Brilliant. So she designed this extra bit of safety for Ed with this floaty bun. And before we shot, they went over to Kent Subornac's pool and they put a stunt guy in the suit and they tested it out. And it worked. Oh my gosh. You're talking about what happens when like someone's riding a horse by an Ed's floating and there's a guy with a rowboat. What about Kent's family? Hey dad, who's in the pool? Don't worry about it. It's a little thing for work. Totally. Totally. Also, when these guys in the writer's room wrote this sequence,
是定制的，对吧？是的。是的。她说，如果我做一个相扑选手发髻形状的漂浮头盔会怎么样？而且这个发髻实际上是一个漂浮装置。太聪明了。所以她用这个漂浮发髻为埃德设计了这额外的安全保障。在我们拍摄之前，他们去了肯·苏博纳克的游泳池，让一个特技演员穿上这套衣服进行了测试。成功了。哦，天哪。你刚才说的是当有人骑着马路过时，看到安迪在漂浮，还有一个人划着划船。肯的家人呢？嘿，爸爸，泳池里是谁？不用担心。这是工作的一点小事。完全是。另外，当编剧室里的这些家伙写下这个序列时，
they had no idea the paces that they would put people through to make it realized on screen. It was just a funny idea. Oh, you know what would be funny? They wrestle in these sumo suits and then Ed falls in the water and floats away. I mean, the amount of effort that went into making that happen. I know. I think about this all the time with our scripts like, oh, it'll be funny. We'll have a funeral for a bird, but we need a specialized tiny coffin made. Yeah. And several dead birds to choose from. And then Jim and Karen sneak off and they're sneaking off to call David. But Pam doesn't know that, but you know she saw them walk away. You know she did. She's aware. Yeah. And they have this moment where
他们完全不知道为了在银幕上呈现出来，他们会经历多少折磨。这只是一个有趣的主意。哦，你知道什么会很有趣吗？他们在相扑服里摔跤，然后安迪掉进水里漂走了。我的意思是，为了让这一切发生所付出的努力。我知道。我常常看着我们的脚本这样想，哦，这会很有趣。我们要为一只鸟举行葬礼，但我们需要制作一个特制的微型棺材。是的。还要有几只死鸟可供选择。然后吉姆和凯伦偷偷溜走，他们溜去给大卫打电话。但帕姆不知道，不过你知道她看到他们走开了。你知道她看到了。她心里有数。是的。然后他们有个时刻
they call David. Jim says he wants to be considered and then Karen does. And then Jim is like teasing her because she sort of fumbles her words when she calls David. Yeah, I didn't think that was cool boyfriend behavior, I have to say. Oh, right. Because she's trying to leave a professional message, right? She's speaking to David Wallace and she's saying she'd like to be considered for this job. And he's kind of heckling her during this phone call and I and he's distracting her. And I know I think it was meant to be kind of like cute and playful. But I don't know. If I'm if I'm making a professional phone call, I don't appreciate being heckled. Don't mess with me. Don't mess with me when I'm
给大卫打电话。吉姆说他想被考虑，然后凯伦也这么说。然后吉姆在逗她，因为她在给大卫打电话时有点语无伦次。是的，我得说，这可不是什么酷男友的行为。哦，对吧？因为她正在试图留下一条专业的语音留言，对吧？她正在和大卫·华盛顿说话，她说她想被考虑这份工作。而他在这通电话中有点在起哄捉弄她，我，他在分散她的注意力。我知道这本意可能是那种可爱俏皮的感觉。但我不知道。如果我在打一个重要的商务电话，我可不感激别人起哄。别惹我。当我
making an important boss lady call. Or is he trying to sabotage? He might be trying to sandwich this moment. He tried to sandwich it. Well, we also mentioned earlier that this was an added scene. Originally, these phone calls happened in the office before we went to beach day, but they made a change and they decided it was better to reveal this information later. But this led to problems like we already had such a packed day and here we were trying to add little moments and add little scenes. And Jen actually talked about this as one of the challenges just trying to get everything shot on these days because you know, you have so many things you have to shoot in daylight and then the sun goes down, you can't make
在打一个重要的女老板电话时，别来烦我。还是他在试图破坏？他可能正试图把这个时刻“三明治”化。他尝试把它三明治化。好吧，我们刚才也提到过，这是一个新增的场景。最初，这些电话是在我们去海滩日之前在办公室里打的，但他们做了改动，觉得最好把这些信息留到后面再揭晓。但这导致了一些问题，比如我们本来就已经有了一个排得满满的一天，而这里我们还试图添加一些小段落和小场景。詹实际上把这当作挑战之一谈过，就是试图在这些天里把所有东西都拍完，因为你知道，你有很多事情必须在白天拍摄，然后太阳下山了，你可没办法让它
it stay out. Also, these were such big ambitious days. And if we would go past the allotted time, we would get into overtime, which was incredibly expensive for the show because they would have to pay the crew overtime, the actors overtime. And so Kent Sabornak, our line producer, was trying to keep us on our day and he was having to check in with Jen and Harold quite a bit about it. Yeah, here's what she had to say about that. And I remember Kent being very patient with us and giving us extra time and adding in cushions, but it was still really difficult to get everything that we needed to get done. I mean, we were going very fast and working incredibly efficiently. It was just hard. And I remember there was
不落山。另外，这些都是如此宏大、雄心勃勃的日子。如果我们超过了规定的时间，我们就会进入加班，这对于剧组来说极其昂贵，因为他们必须支付剧组加班费、演员加班费。所以我们的制片主任肯·苏博纳克试图让我们按日程进行，他不得不就此与詹和哈罗德进行相当多的沟通。是的，她是这么说的。我记得肯对我们非常有耐心，给我们留出了额外的缓冲时间，还增加了缓冲，但要把需要完成的所有事情都拍完依然非常困难。我的意思是，我们进展得非常快，工作效率高得惊人。只是真的很艰难。我记得有
one moment where Kent had already given us a cushion and maybe even a second cushion. And then we were about to go over it, but we were almost done. We were so close to being done, but Kent called and I got the call and we were about ready to say, you know, Harold was about ready to call action. And Kent is like frustrated because he wants us to be done because he's given us extra time and he wants us to be done and completely understandable. But I knew that if I kept talking to Kent, we were going to be slowed down by 10 seconds at that point and that 10 seconds would allow us to finish the shot. So Ken is talking to me and a very gently and gingerly just put the phone down on a chair and we got the last
那么一会儿，肯已经给我们留出了缓冲时间，甚至可能是第二个缓冲时间。然后我们快要超过那个时间了，但我们马上就要拍完了。我们离完成只有一步之遥，但肯打来电话，我接了电话，我们正准备说，你知道的，哈罗德正准备喊“Action”。而肯很沮丧，因为他希望我们收工，因为他已经给了我们额外的时间，他希望我们收工并且完全可以理解。但我知道如果我继续和肯说话，当时我们的进度就会被拖慢10秒钟，而那10秒钟就能让我们拍完那个镜头。所以肯在跟我说话，我非常轻柔小心地把电话放在椅子上，我们拍完了最后
shot and we were done. It was definitely this weird moment of like, this is the producer of your show telling you that you need to stop shooting. And I realized I can either talk to him about the fact that we're going to stop shooting or get the shot. So we got the shot. It was definitely one of those moments of like, I hope that was cool. Angela, I think that what Jen is talking about is a little bit of sabotage. She's sabotaging. She's not sabotaging. She's sabotaging her phone call so that they could get these shots. I think it's pretty amazing. Like I can sort of just visualize Kent going on and on like, man, you can't keep adding scenes and she just set the phone down and was like, yes,
一个镜头，然后我们就收工了。这绝对是一个奇怪的时刻，就像是：这是你节目的制片人，他在告诉你你需要停止拍摄。我意识到要么我可以跟他谈谈我们要停止拍摄这件事，要么就把镜头拍下来。所以我们把镜头拍下来了。这绝对是那种“我希望这没问题”的时刻。安吉拉，我觉得詹在谈论的这其实就是一种破坏。她在破坏。她没有破坏。她在破坏她的电话，这样他们才能拍完这些镜头。我觉得这太惊人了。就像我脑海中能浮现出肯喋喋不休的样子，天哪，你不能一直加戏，而她只是放下电话说，太棒了，
do it one more time. One more time while he's venting. Yes, exactly. Well, you guys, part of Kent's job, he has such a hard job because he answers to both Greg, who is the creative voice of the show. And you know, his job is to make all of Greg's dreams come true creatively, but he also answers to the network who has given him a budget and a timetable and you can't spend more money than this. And everything that you said earlier, Angela, about staying on time because Kent will look at a script and he will try to estimate based on conversations with the director and the writer and the crew how long each scene will take. So he'll say, all right, we need three hours to film Ed at sea. But I'm only going to give 45 minutes
再来一次。趁他在发泄情绪的时候再来一次。是的，完全是这样。好吧，伙计们，肯的工作的一部分，他的工作太难了，因为他既要对格雷格负责，格雷格是节目的创意之声。你知道，他的工作就是从创意上实现格雷格的所有梦想，但他也要对电视台负责，电视台给了他预算和时间表，你花的钱不能超过这个。而你刚才说的所有关于保持准时的内容，安吉拉，因为肯会看剧本，他会根据与导演、编剧和剧组的对话，试图估算每个场景需要多长时间。所以他会说，好吧，我们需要三个小时来拍摄埃德在海里的戏。但我只打算给45分钟。
to Jim and Karen in the sand. That's right. And if any of these things go over even 10 minutes, they have to steal 10 minutes from another scene. And it is becomes just this logistical nightmare and Kent has to keep an eye on all of it. And it is a vicious domino effect too. Once you get off, it just spirals your whole day. I feel like this is like a great metaphor for partnerships because I feel like in every family, there's one person that's a little bit of the big thinker dreamer on vacation will do all of this. And then there's the person in the relationship that's like, I've allotted $80 for things at the gift shop. That's all we're spending at the gift shop.
吉姆和凯伦就在沙滩上。没错。如果其中任何一个环节超时哪怕10分钟，他们就得从另一个场景里扣除10分钟。这简直成了一场后勤噩梦，肯特必须时刻盯着所有这些。而且这也会产生残酷的多米诺骨效应。一旦时间乱了，你整天 的行程都会陷入混乱。我觉得这就像是关于伴侣关系的一个很好的比喻，因为我觉得在每个家庭里，总有一个人有点像那种会包揽度假所有安排的宏观思考梦想家。然后关系里还有另一个人会说：“我给礼品店的东西只分配了80美元预算。我们在礼品店就花这么多。”
Okay. Because if we spend more than $80 at the gift shop, we can't do that extra bungee cord thing that you all want to do. Yes. That is exactly Kent. He is that person. Keep us on budget. Keep us on time. Yep. Well, now, Angela, it is time for the cold walk. Talk about a big scene. This was a big evening for us. It was a very ambitious shoot. We had a lot to cover. We could not start till it got dark. Yep. And there was a lot of prep. I don't know if you remember, Jenna, how they made those coals. Do you remember? I do. It was multi-layered. And we had a lot of people ask this question about how did you make the coals? We got mail from Ellie Troutman, Chandra M., Jamie S., Heather Donnelly,
好的。因为如果我们在这家礼品店花了超过80美元，我们就没法玩你们大家都很想玩的那个额外的蹦极项目了。是的。这完全就是肯特。他就是那种人。让我们保持在预算内。让我们不超时。是的。好了，现在，安吉拉，是时候迎来冷步行了。说起一个大场面。这对我们来说是一个很大的夜晚。这是一次雄心勃勃的拍摄。我们有很多内容要拍。天黑之前我们都不能开拍。是的。而且有很多筹备工作。我不知道你是否还记得，珍娜，他们是怎么制作那些煤块的。你还记得吗？我记得。它是多层的。我们有很多人问过这个问题：你们是怎么制作那些煤块的？我们收到了埃莉·特劳特曼、钱德拉·M、杰米·S、希瑟·唐纳利，
Renee R., and many others. They wanted to know, how did the props department create the hot coals? They looked so real. Because, guys, these were not real coals. Yes. So we could not have a huge fire here, you guys. We were allowed to have the tiki torches and little small flames. For example, when the pile of wood burst into flames, that's all special effects. That was not at all a fire. They put that in in post because there were fire regulations at this particular park, right? Well, there are fire regulations in California in general. Yes. Yes, absolutely. So Harold Ramis talked a little bit about this coal fire pit on the DVD commentary. He said they started, first of all, by digging a big hole
蕾妮·R以及许多其他人的来信。他们想知道，道具部门是怎么制作那些烧红的煤块的？它们看起来那么真实。因为，伙计们，这些根本不是真的煤块。是的。所以我们不能在这里搞一场大火，伙计们。我们只被允许使用火把和小小的火焰。例如，当木堆突然窜起火焰时，那全都是特效。那根本不是什么火。那是后期加上去的，因为这个特定的公园有消防规定，对吧？嗯，加州总的来说都有消防规定。是的。是的，绝对的。所以哈罗德·雷米斯在DVD评论音轨里稍微谈到了这个炭火坑。他说他们首先是通过在地上挖一个大洞开始的，
in the ground. And then they buried in the ground a light box, just a big box that lit up. And then they put on top of the light box these little yellow and orange gels to make it look like a flame. And then on top of those light gels, on top of the light box, they put little lava rocks. And then running on either side of this hole in the ground, they had put two gas lines with very small little flickers of real fire that popped out of the ground. Yes. And because there was real fire as part of the coal walk, we had a very big safety meeting about that. One of our biggest. Yeah. For sure. It's particularly important because, as you know, rain as Dwight is going to walk onto these hot coals, stand
在地下。然后在地下埋了一个灯箱，就是一个会发光的巨大箱子。然后他们在灯箱上面放了这些黄色和橙色的滤光胶片，让它看起来像火焰。接着，在这些灯光滤光片上方、灯箱上方，他们放了小块的火山岩。然后在这处地下洞穴的两侧，他们铺设了两条天然气管道，管道里有非常微小的、从地面冒出来的真实火焰。是的。由于炭火步行中包含了真正的火焰，我们为此开了一个非常大的安全会议。这是我们最大的一次会议之一。是的。肯定的。这尤其重要，因为，如你所知，当德怀特要走上这些炽热的煤炭时，站在
there and then follow the ground. And that was real fire next to him. On either side of him. Yes. And I remember when rain did that, one of the most painful things for rain was being barefoot on the lava rocks. It hurt. It's like stepping on a Lego. You know how that feels. I do know how it feels because I did it as well. Yeah. In fact, I'll say that people have mentioned that I look like my feet really hurt after I walk across the hot coals and they've wondered if I really walked on hot coals. No, my feet were sore and bruised from having to run across lava rocks over and over again. Yeah. Like my feet did kind of hurt. Throw a bunch of like hard Legos on the ground and run back and forth
那里然后倒在地上。他旁边就是真正的火。在他两侧。是的。我记得当雷恩那样做时，对雷恩来说最痛苦的事情之一就是赤脚踩在火山岩上。很痛。就像踩在乐高积木上一样。你知道那种感觉。我确实知道那种感觉，因为我也经历过。是的。事实上，我要说的是，人们提到过，在我走过炭火之后，我的脚看起来真的很痛，他们想知道我是不是真的走在热炭上。不，我的脚又酸又痛，因为不得不一遍又一遍地跑过火山岩。是的。我的脚确实有点痛。把一堆硬邦邦的乐高积木扔在地上，然后来回奔跑
over them. That's as good as a coal walk right there. A Lego walk. If you want that experience, you can do it at home. Michael wanted everyone to walk over the hot coals. We said he has to go first in Steve's hesitation as Michael to go over those coals. Jenna was so brilliant. His whole body posture, the expression on his face, and he improvised the line, the mind has to wrap around the foot. I love that that was an improvisation. I did not look that up. I love knowing that. And we have a call back to this whole runner of Angela being grossed out by Kevin's feet. Yes, that's right. She's like, I am not going to go after you and your gross feet. And he's like, Angela, it's like a thousand degrees.
踩在它们上面。这就跟走炭火差不多了。乐高步行。如果你想要这种体验，你在家里就能做。迈克尔希望每个人都走过热炭。我们说他必须第一个上，史蒂夫在饰演迈克尔要走过那些炭火时的犹豫。珍娜太绝了。他的整个身体姿势、脸上的表情，还有他即兴说出的台词：“思维必须适应双脚。”我好喜欢那是一段即兴发挥。我没有去查过这个。我很高兴能知道这一点。而且我们这里呼应了安吉拉对凯文的脚感到恶心的那个梗。是的，没错。她说：“我才不要走在你和你的恶心脚后面呢。”而他说：“安吉拉，这有一千度呢。”
One of my favorite moments in this whole sequence is when Michael says to the group, he's so disappointed that no one has walked across the coals except sort of Dwight. And he says, you know what? It's clear to me that if I had to name my replacement today, it would be Mr. Outside Hire. And then Angela says, or Mrs. Outside Hire. And Michael is like, yes, or that. He's so condescending. It made me laugh so hard. I know, but a little bit of Angela sass there, like I pointed my finger. Yeah. Wait, Jenna, we do have a background catch. We can't pass up. It's too good. Say it. While Michael's going on and on about who won't walk across the coals. And he's like, and Andy is never here today. It pans past
在这整个桥段中，我最喜欢的时刻之一就是迈克尔对大家说，除了德怀特勉强算之外，没有人走过炭火，他感到非常失望。然后他说：“你知道吗？我很清楚，如果我今天必须指定我的接班人，那就是外聘先生。”然后安吉拉说：“或者是外聘女士。”迈克尔就说：“对，或者那个。”他太居高临职务了。这让我笑得前仰后合。我懂，但安吉拉在那里表现出了一点傲慢，就像我指了指那样。是的。等等，珍娜，我们确实抓到了一个背景彩蛋。我们不能错过。太棒了。说吧。当迈克尔喋喋不休地抱怨谁不肯走过炭火时。他说：“而且安迪今天根本不在这里。”镜头摇过了
us to the water. Andy has floated into the marsh. He's stuck on his back, poor Ed in the dark in the lake. And at 19 minutes, 55 seconds, you can see his wetsuit on his arm. Oh, yeah. On his arm. His arm is like extended out of his sumo suit. And you can see the beige wetsuit that he had to put on because it was so cold. And then people wrote in Angela and they said, how come in season nine, when Pam is crying, the documentary crew helps her. But when Andy is floating away at night, they just turn off the camera lights and walk away. I know. I know. That's one of the questions Jack had. My stepson, he was like, why did the camera crew not help him? I know. And I was like, you know what? At that moment,
我们看向水面。安迪已经漂进了沼泽里。他仰面朝天地卡在那里，可怜的埃德在湖里黑暗中。在19分55秒时，你可以看到他胳膊上的潜水服。哦，对。在他的胳膊上。他的胳膊就像是从他的相扑服里伸出来一样。你可以看到他不得不穿上的米色潜水服，因为当时太冷了。然后人们写信给安吉拉，他们说，为什么在第九季里，当帕姆哭泣时，纪录片摄制组会帮助她？但当安迪在夜里漂走时，他们却只是关掉摄像机灯光然后走开。我知道。我知道。那是杰克问的问题之一。我的继子，他当时就问：“为什么摄像机摄制组不帮他？”我懂。然后我说：“你知道吗？在那一刻，
they were like, we can't disturb the natural course of the story. Right. We must just document it. Well, we're coming up to this big moment. There is a huge moment about to happen for Pam. Yeah. She wants to run across the coals and Michael says no. No. Yeah. And he moves them on and he wants them all to speak Dwight is doing his version of the aristocrats very badly. And in the background, Pam runs across the coals. Yeah. And this just feeds her soul. She feels so alive in this moment. She did this one thing for herself and she runs over to the group and she wants to share. Yeah. And she gives this speech and everything just comes pouring out her disappointment that people didn't come to the art show. But
他们觉得，我们不能打乱故事的自然发展进程。没错。我们必须只是记录它。好吧，我们马上要迎来这个重大时刻了。帕姆即将迎来一个极其重大的时刻。是的。她想跑过炭火，而迈克尔说不。不。是的。然后他让他们继续前进，并希望他们全都开口说话，德怀特正在非常糟糕地表演他那个版本的“贵族”笑话。而在背景中，帕姆跑过了炭火。是的。这简直滋养了她的灵魂。她在这个时刻感到了无比的充满生机。她为自己做了这一件事，然后她跑向大家，她想要分享。是的。她发表了这番演讲，所有的事情都倾泻而出——她对大家没有去参加艺术展的失望，但
more than that, her feelings for Jim and how much she misses him and the truth, the big truth, which is that while there were many reasons to call off her wedding to Roy, the reason she did it was because of how she feels about Jim. Yeah. And oof. First of all, I sat next to John in the scene. Angela and Jim are side by side. I don't know if you noticed that. I did. And so when you were talking to Jim, I was right in your eye line. You know, I couldn't believe my luck, honestly, because this is such a beautiful performance by you, Jenna. You do such a great job. It's so moving to watch you as Pam transition through all of those beats. And I had this out of body experience as your friend watching you
更重要的是，她对吉姆的感情以及她有多么想念他，还有真相，最大的真相——那就是，尽管取消与罗伊的婚礼有许多原因，但她这样做的原因是因为她对吉姆的感情。是的。而且，哎呀。首先，我在那个场景里坐在约翰旁边。安吉拉和吉姆并肩而坐。我不知道你有没有注意到这一点。我注意到了。所以当你和吉姆说话时，我就在你的视线正前方。你知道，老实说，我简直不敢相信自己的好运，因为这是你非常精彩的一段表演，珍娜。你演得太棒了。看着你饰演的帕姆经历所有这些情绪转折，实在是太感人了。我有一种灵魂出窍的体验，作为你的朋友，看着你
in awe, give this fantastic performance, wanting to tear up and cry because my friend was crushing it. And then having to be Angela Martin, who would never react to you that way. And then at the same time, just being in awe of this moment, it was, it was just a beautiful thing to watch. Jenna, you did such a great job and you had to do it over and over. We did several takes because they had to get people's reactions. And every time you crushed it every single time. Well, a lot of people ask if that speech was improvised or partially improvised. And it was not. That was all written. And as Jen shared with us written by Greg Daniels, and I memorized it and delivered it word for word. I worked on it for a very long time.
惊叹不已，奉献了如此精彩的表演，想要落泪和哭泣，因为我的朋友简直演得太炸裂了。然后又不得不做回安吉拉·马丁，她绝不会对你有那种反应。与此同时，只是对这个时刻感到惊叹，那真的是，那真的是一个美好的观赏时刻。珍娜，你演得太棒了，而且你不得不一遍又一遍地拍。我们拍了好几个镜次，因为他们必须拍到大家的反应。每一次，你都每一次都完美驾驭。嗯，很多人问那段演讲是即兴的还是部分即兴的。其实并不是。那全都是写好的。正如珍跟我们分享的那样，那是格雷格·丹尼尔斯写的，我把它背了下来，并且一字不差地表演出。我为它准备了非常长的时间。
And I remember, I remember trying to think about those times in my life where you've done something that give you a burst of adrenaline. And that's what I wanted her to come into the speech with. She's just done this call walk. And she has this burst of adrenaline. And she doesn't even think about that she's going to share. It's it's completely different. This is very impulsive. And that was that was kind of what I put behind the speech. But I knew that speech backwards and forwards, I could have delivered it for days. Because I also know as an actor, at least for me, especially, the more I know the material, the less I have to think of the word. Exactly. And it can just be about the performance.
而且我记得，我记得尝试去回想我生命中那些你做过某件事从而带来一波肾上腺素飙升的时刻。这就是我想让她带入这段演讲中的状态。她刚刚完成了炭火步行。她体内有一股肾上腺素飙升。她甚至都没有去想她将要分享什么——这完全是不同的。这是非常冲动的。那就是我赋予这段演讲背后的东西。但我对这段演讲倒背如流，我可以说上好几天。因为我也知道，作为一名演员，至少对我来说，尤其如此，我对素材越熟悉，我就越不需要去思考台词。没错。它就可以完全关乎表演。
I was I never had to search for it. I had it. It was like a little tape in my head. That's exactly right. You don't have to worry about what you're saying. And you can just really experience the moment and feel it. Because the words are all there. And I just thought it was brilliant. And I thought everyone's reactions were great. Because there's there's there is a dance that you do on a show like the office. There is the person who is driving the scene, who's putting out all this information. And then the other side of the story is the people reacting to it. And the two parts are very important. And I thought that John is Jim, his reactions were great. Everyone in the crowd, they cut to Rashida. Oh my God,
我从来不需要去寻找台词。我全掌握了。它就像我脑海里的一小段磁带。完全正确。你不需要担心你在说什么。你可以真正地体验这个时刻并去感受它。因为台词都在那里。我只是觉得它太精彩了。而且我觉得大家的反应都很棒。因为在像《办公室》这样的剧里，你确实在跳一支舞。有一种人在推动场景，抛出所有这些信息。然后故事的另一面是对此做出反应的人。这两个部分都非常重要。我觉得约翰饰演的吉姆，他的反应太棒了。人群中的每个人，镜头切到拉什达——天哪，
her look is Karen was amazing. It was like, I can't believe this is happening. Oh my God, it was everything. And also heartbreak. It was all of it. Yeah. Well, and you mentioned about what it's like to be the person driving a scene. This was kind of my first experience with that. And it was this huge speech. And that's another reason why I made sure I knew every single word. And I got a real glimpse at what Steve does every single day, every single week. Wow, delivering these big speeches to the group. I mean, all your eyeballs were on me. I was so nervous. Yeah, it's a lot of work. It's a lot of work. And not just the cast watching you, the whole
她的表情，凯伦的表情太绝了。那感觉就像是，我简直不敢相信这正在发生。天哪，那简直包罗万象。还有心碎。全都有。是的。嗯，你提到了作为推动场景的人是什么感觉。这算是我对此的第一次体验。而且这是一段非常宏大的演讲。这也是为什么我确保自己知道每一个字的原因。我真正一窥了史蒂夫每天、每周都在做的事情。哇，向大家发表这些大型演讲。我的意思是，所有人的目光都落在我身上。我太紧张了。是的，这工作量很大。这工作量很大。不仅仅是演员看着你，整个
crew, it's everything. Yeah. Well, I thought it was so great. I just loved it so much. Well thank you. You know, I hadn't seen it since it first aired. And when I watched it, I was really proud of myself. You should be. I was like, oh my gosh, I love that that performance is on tape and I can watch it later because it really made me feel like a good actress. I was like, oh, look at me go. You are a good actress. You should. You should feel that way. You should. Well, I was always, I was always curious why they sat me next to Jim and didn't have Karen next to him. And then that moment ends with Jim looking straight ahead and me kind of looking off to the side like, oh my God. Yeah, I think you are there
剧组，一切都在看着。是的。嗯，我觉得太棒了。我太喜欢了。那谢谢你。你知道的，自从它首播以来我就没再看过。当我看到它时，我真的为自己感到骄傲。你理应如此。我当时想，噢天哪，我太喜欢这段表演被录下来了，以后我还可以看，因为它真的让我觉得自己是个好演员。我当时想，噢，瞧瞧我多棒。你是个好演员。你应该。你应该有这种感觉。你必须的。嗯，我一直，我一直很好奇为什么他们让我坐在吉姆旁边，而不是让凯伦坐在他旁边。然后那个时刻以吉姆目视前方结束，而我则有点把视线投向一旁，仿佛在说：噢天哪。是的，我觉得你在那里
to be the audience reflected, right? You're what everyone at home is like, whoa. So I think it was good to have you there being that other piece of the conversation. Yeah. But you know, the episode was supposed to end there in the script. That's the end of the episode. But we added a little tag back on the bus singing on the bus. And this tag confused a lot of people. Well, it's daytime. We're clearly happy. None of this has happened. It doesn't make any time sequential sense, right? Yes. Everyone wanted to know, did you sleep at the beach? You're all in the same clothes. How does everyone look like they've bathed if they spent the night at the beach? They just threw this tag on the
是为了成为观众的映射，对吧？你就是家里每个人的缩影，仿佛在说：哇。所以我觉得你在那里作为对话的另一个部分是很好的。对。但你知道的，剧本里这一集本该到此结束。那是这一集的结尾。但在公交车上唱歌的彩蛋里，我们又加了一个小片段。这个彩蛋让很多人感到困惑。嗯，那是白天。我们显然很高兴。这些事全都没发生过。从时间顺序上来说完全不合理，对吧？是的。每个人都想问，你们是在海滩上睡觉了吗？你们穿着同样的衣服。如果大家在海滩过夜，怎么每个人看起来都洗过澡一样？他们只是把这个彩蛋加在
end. It was an extra little bit of fun from the episode. It was not meant to be sequential. We did not spend the night at the beach story wise. Yeah, they just in editing, they liked it. They liked to end on this sort of upbeat, you know, there's this huge emotional moment has just happened. And then it's us all as a group. And Ed said in the DVD commentary that he started the song, The Flintstones on the bus. And for him, it was a nod to planes, trains and automobiles. Which I love. I love that too. You know, they do something similar in the Valentine's Day episode. They had that little bit of extra footage of Steve improvising in front of the theater. And they threw that bit on the end as a tag for Valentine's Day.
最后。这是剧集里一点额外的小乐趣。它本意并非按时间顺序。从剧情上讲，我们并没有在海滩过夜。是的，他们只是在剪辑时觉得挺好。他们喜欢以这种轻松愉快的方式结束，你知道的，刚刚发生了这么巨大的情感时刻。然后是我们大家作为一个群体。埃德在DVD评论音轨中说，他在公交车上起头唱了那首歌《摩登原始人》。对他来说，这是向《飞机、火车和汽车》致敬。我很喜欢这个。我也很喜欢这个。你知道的，他们在情人节那一集里做了类似的事。他们加入了史蒂夫在剧院前面即兴表演的那一小段额外素材。他们把那段放到了最后，作为情人节那一集的彩蛋。
So it's just something we did sometimes. Yeah. And I think you can get away with that in a cold open and a tag. They sort of can be their little standalone moments. But Jenna, before we wrap this up, I wrote about some of my memories of filming this episode in my journal. And I said, one of the things I loved is that Rashida and I had our trailers side by side in the parking lot. And we weren't very far away. We were just really close to the catering truck. And so in the morning, Harold Ramis would get his coffee and Jen and they would have to walk past Rashida and I. And we would sit on like the front steps of my trailer, like it was our front stoop, right? Yeah. And we would visit in the mornings
所以这只是我们有时会做的事情。是的。而且我觉得你在冷开场和彩蛋里完全可以这么做。它们某种程度上可以成为它们自己的独立小片段。但是珍娜，在我们结束之前，我在日记里写下了一些我拍摄这一集的记忆。我说，我喜欢的一件事是，拉什达和我在停车场拥有彼此相邻的拖车。而且我们离得不是很远。我们离餐饮卡车非常近。所以在早上，哈罗德·雷米斯会去拿他的咖啡，然后珍，他们必须从拉什达和我身边走过。我们会坐在我拖车的台阶上，就像那是我们的门前台阶一样，对吧？是的。我们会在早上去拜访
with Harold and Jen. And I have a photo of us and, you know, having our coffee in the morning. I just love it. I love that. I love that. I love that memory so much. I don't know if we can say enough what an honor and pleasure it was to work with him. But Jen also mentioned this in one of her audio clips. Yeah. What it meant to her to have the opportunity to work with him. I'm so glad he was the person in charge of this crazy, crazy episode. Yes, because he was such a delight. Jenna, I remembered as I was going through photos, do you remember because him and Jen had to be kind of far away where we were filming that he had a microphone and he would give sort of big general notes on this microphone. And then we would yell
哈罗德和珍。我有一张我们的合影，你知道的，大家早上一起喝咖啡。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢这个记忆了。我不知道我们是否能足够地表达出能与他合作是多么荣幸和愉快。但珍也在她的其中一个音频片段里提到了这一点。是的。这对于她有机会与他合作意味着什么。我很高兴他是负责这一集疯狂、疯狂内容的负责人。是的，因为他太令人愉快了。珍娜，当我在翻看照片时我想起来了，你还记得吗，因为他和珍必须离我们拍摄的地方有点远，所以他有一个麦克风，他会在这个麦克风上给出一些宏观的大体意见。然后我们会冲
at him to tell us jokes and he would tell us jokes. And in the DVD rain, they said that rain would say, tell us more about Groundhog Day. He would share little bits of trivia on this microphone to us, you know, as we were way far away on the beach. And he just made it all so fun. Well, Jen mentioned that he was really instrumental in mentoring her. And actually, Sam, why don't you play that clip? One moment. Another thing that happened on that episode was there was a there was a it was a challenging episode because we had a lot to get and and the elements were tricky to I remember it was like incredibly cold and there were heat lamps and it was also scorching hot sometimes and within the course
他大喊让他给我们讲笑话，他就会给我们讲笑话。在DVD里，雷恩说，雷恩会说：“给我们多讲讲《土拨鼠之日》的事吧。”你知道的，当我们在远处的沙滩上时，他会在这个麦克风上跟我们分享一点点花絮。他让这一切变得如此有趣。嗯，珍提到他在指导她方面确实起到了关键作用。实际上，萨姆，你为什么不播放那个片段呢？等一下。那一集里发生的另一件事是，那一集具有挑战性，因为我们有很多东西要拍，而且客观环境很棘手。我记得当时冷得难以置信，有热灯，有时温度又高得灼人，就在
of one day. So there were a lot of additional challenges that episode and there was one day where it was like we were not going to make our day by sunset. We had just way more to shoot than was actually possible to shoot in that day with our challenges. And he said to me at one point, Jen, let's like divide up you work with the actors and I'll do the tech stuff. And it was only for a brief amount of time. But it was one of just a thrill of mine that I was able to do that and kind of start talking to the actors in a slightly different way and start thinking about the course of being a director. And it all started with that episode on him giving me a little bit of that responsibility because there was
一天之内。所以那一集有很多额外的挑战，有一天我们眼看就要在日落前完工无望了。我们在那天面对挑战实际能拍完的内容，要比我们真正需要拍的多得多。他当时对我说：“珍，我们分工一下吧，你跟演员们合作，我来搞定技术方面的事。”这只持续了很短的一段时间。但这对我来说简直是一大震撼人心的体验，我能够做到这一点，并且开始以一种略微不同的方式与演员们对话，开始思考成为一名导演的历程。这一切都始于那一集，他交给了我一点点责任，因为
just too much to get done. I'm so grateful for Harold. And I it's one of the biggest thrills of my career that I got to work with him. And guys, Jen ended up directing two episodes of the office. She directed crime aid and the promotion. It just fits so perfectly that he extended that to her and shared that with her. And how lucky were we? Yeah. Well, guys, that's Beach Games. That is Beach Games. Thank you so much for listening. This was so wonderful to rewatch.
实在有太多事情要完成了。我非常感谢哈罗德。能有机会跟他合作是我职业生涯中最震撼的体验之一。伙计们，珍最后执导了《办公室》的两集。她执导了《犯罪援助》和《升职》。他把这个机会延伸给她并与她分享，这一切简直是天作之合。我们是多么幸运啊。好吧，伙计们，这就是《海滩运动会》。这就是《海滩运动会》。非常感谢你们的收听。重温这一集真是太美妙了。
I loved it. I loved it. This was one of my favorite weeks to prepare. Me too. For sure. Yeah. And to shoot. We got to live it and relive it. What a gift. Well, next week we have a really big week. It's the job and we're wrapping up season three. Now, we're going to divide the job into two parts because it's an hour long episode.
我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。这是我最喜欢的准备周之一。我也是。肯定的。是的。还有拍摄。我们去体验了它，并重温了它。这真是一份厚礼。好吧，下周我们有一个非常重大的星期。那就是《工作》那一集，我们要为第三季画上句号。现在，我们要把《工作》分成两部分，因为它是一个小时长的剧集。
We're going to have the job part one and the job part two, but it's all going to be good. All right, guys, we'll see you next week. Have a good one. We love you. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Irwin, Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kieffer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubacow. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month
我们将有《工作》（上）和《工作》（下），但这一切都会很精彩。好了，伙计们，我们下周见。祝你们过得愉快。我们爱你们。感谢收听《办公室女孩》。《办公室女孩》由埃尔文、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布巴科夫。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。若想收听无广告版本的《办公室女孩》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。若想获得一个月的免费
trial of StitcherPremium, use code OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
试用 StitcherPremium，请使用兑换码 OFFICE。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。